foreign
[Music]
yeah what's up with this you look pale
as [__] that's okay that's that's what
we want that's what we like we like that
all right what's up got people in there
already yeah wands in there
hey everybody
Celtic Angels saying that her and her
boyfriend saw some uh movies that you
you'd probably like yeah we
um I actually am looking for
recommendations because
um you know for the matinee show on
Sunday you know for the past several
weeks we've been doing
um movies that got sent to us like
xanadas sent us a whole bunch and I
think Louie had sent us a couple and so
we've been doing those and I was like
um you know this week we don't have one
and so I was like I want to do more
horror movies I feel like so I've been
looking for recommendations for horror
movies and anything that's on shutter or
Amazon Prime or Hulu or 2B or anything
like that that I can watch and that
would be good I have an idea for one
that I want to do that I've seen like
recommended on some other horror
channels that's on shutter but we'll see
that's we'll see if we're in the mood
for it or we might go the route where
we can watch like an older one that we
haven't reviewed like for example HBO
Max has like some old like 80 Stephen
King ones that we haven't done like
silver bullet and thinner and stuff like
that I don't think we've done those and
also it has HBO Max has um onibaba which
I've actually been wanting to do
so like that Japanese ghost story movie
I did quiet on like on my own channel
because HBO Max has that too but I
haven't done only Bombay only Bobby yet
but yeah that light is changing back
there I know it does that all the time I
don't know what the [__] its problem is
so it's like we're getting all kinds of
new ones yeah I mean if uh I wonder if
she and Carries those probably they have
like all the little neon [__] and
everything like that like yeah Neon
cherries and one you gotta do some
shopping anyway there yeah I mean I
can't spend all my money there but we've
already spent like I should tell yeah
[__] ton of money I got like
I got like a whole bunch of new dresses
I got a whole but I got in some new
shoes I got like some jewelry I got some
hair pieces I got yeah shoes yeah I said
that [__] ton of dresses
yeah what else do you want you made a
big order of like a bunch of tops and
stuff yeah yeah like yeah
um there's like a vest in there that
might fit me we'll see when it comes if
not if it fit yet it's pretty cool it's
fur
yeah it's pretty cool yeah it's fur and
it looks like I mean it could you could
wear it or I could wear it it doesn't
really matter yeah it's a werewolf
looking chick
murder Hornets dead crosses and [__]
yeah it's cool got the crosses and
[__] fur collars around the [__]
neck and around the arms and it's a
short it's a short vest it's only only
yeah it's like gray right it's gray yeah
yeah it's only the top half of your body
it's pretty cool looking murderheart had
said my ex said the new Transformer
movie is good
I mean probably there's a new
Transformer movie yeah yeah I didn't
even know that I didn't know that
either well I haven't really been
Michael Bay
wait I don't know I don't know I don't
know I haven't kept really the only
Transformer movies that we saw didn't we
see the Bumblebee one bumblebee yeah
that's okay which that was okay yeah
like um you know I'm not real up on the
lore or anything and like I said I'm not
you know I've said this a million times
I'm not like usually like a big fan of
big tent pole type movies like The
expectable type movie some of them are
good and like they're usually
entertaining but it's not really my
thing and usually I don't go out of my
way to see them
you know it's just
um I think it was I think Tammy because
Tammy's in here right yeah Tammy sent me
a message on Facebook earlier today
um and she sent me the trailer for um
the new the Robert Eggers movie he's
remade Nosferatu okay and it looks cool
as [__] when's that out I don't know
it's like I forgot
yeah this you know the same guy that
made um the witch and the lighthouse and
all that like he's remade nosferati but
I'm like man he's the dude to do it so
we'll see how that goes
you still haven't seen shadow of the
vampire have you
the one that's like about the making of
Nosferatu no with Willem Dafoe and uh
John Malkovich oh it's good it's good
yeah I watched it again like probably a
year or two ago and it was just as good
as I remembered
just as good as I remembered but yeah so
um
Celtic Angel 73 said new season of black
phone started yesterday I wish there
would be another season of Mind Hunter
yeah I think everybody is wishing
there'd be a new season of Mind Hunter
because that kicked ass
yeah Tammy said they just wrapped
filming it the nosferachi that's right
yeah that's right that's what you said
that was like several hours ago and I
kind of forgot I don't remember what
mind Hunter was it was the one that was
on um it was the one with um [__] what's
his [__] name
all right all right all right you know
Woody Harrelson
and that where it's kind of about like
um the start of like the FBI like the
serial killer unit and yeah yeah
that was like yeah it was like really
good we watched it together we really
liked it but yeah everybody's kind of
wondering oh okay yeah yeah
it was called mine Hunters yeah I
thought that was called True Detective
no no wait oh wait maybe I am confusing
it
yeah maybe that was True Detective yeah
with Woody Harrelson yeah I'm getting
them confused it's been a while since
we've seen them I think and I'm getting
old my brains turned into Swiss cheese
after your Detective season one yeah but
we saw mine Hunters here that was on is
that on Netflix I want to say it's on
Netflix
wait am I see in true detector season
one again didn't somebody send us that
don't I have that yeah I think we have
it I have that yeah I think that might
that might have been uh uh Louis huh I
think Louie sent that yeah now I can't
remember it was a while back it was
great it was great
I still gotta keep watching um uh bass
Motel also because Celtic Angel sent
that yeah like I'm through I'm I got all
the way through season one and I'm in
the middle of season two did you do a
season one review not yet okay I gotta
do that yeah I got to do that I just got
I gotta write I gotta write a review for
it
okay before I forget
yeah Celtic Angel 73 said yep Netflix
yeah that's what I thought yeah see I
was getting it confused with True
Detective though which was also good
but it was kind of but mindhunter was
about
the start of the serial killer
behavioral
thing generous looks cute on you thank
you yeah she's she's uh got her little
legs and she's Barefoot got these little
feet scissors right here I love my
little feet too he says yeah I thought
you did it like she got that dress she
got that dress I like these feet now
okay
she got this dress from Sheen and wait a
minute I think we only paid like six
bucks for that thing it's [__]
awesome
we got another one if you like it too
but it's a different pattern it always
make me like unfold my last picture with
some chick with guns on it I think don't
it I don't even know what it is yeah it
says
what does it say let's come back here
it says come alive
the night time or something turn
sideways so you can see what it looks
like let's turn it down there you go
it's pretty nice yeah yeah it's nice
it's real stretch to fit okay now I
gotta yeah
because I can't sit in this damn chair
and I gotta
yeah put my legs up yeah he is always
making me unfold
uh let's see yeah grandpar says uh True
Detective season one was great season
two and three not nearly as good yeah I
mean the first season was the best one
season two is okay though yeah remember
season two being okay yeah
Isabella says you might like
predestination if you haven't seen it
Ethan Hawke time travel that sounds
awfully familiar
did I see that
hmm
I can't remember now I do like Ethan
Hawke though I was watching a video
earlier today
like just trying to you know kind of
narrow down my choices of like you know
the movie that we were gonna do for
matinee and I was like there's this one
guy what the [__] is his name no I can't
this is terrible I can't ever remember
like anybody's Channel names but it's
like I watch him sometimes because he
always does these good lists of like you
know the 10 10 hidden gems on shutter or
10 hidden gems on 2B or whatever and so
he went on there and he had like a
really good list I thought at least of
the ones that I had seen
um he picked out a few that I had really
liked
um like lucky and I think he had super
host on there which I don't think I
watched I watched the one that was just
called host that was all about the
laptop got a pretty good uh crowd coming
in 14 to 18 people if you guys hit the
like button for us please that really
helped us out uh welcome uh to this to
to the show uh
we are gonna Usher in the weekend for
you
it's Friday night God I'm so [__]
glad you're done [__] working
we're working [__] or whatever it is
that you do for us it's like the same
things
well
we'll get like that
yeah we uh uh we're not going out
tonight are we I don't think so okay I
mean unless you really really want to I
don't really feel like it I don't really
slept all day baby I don't really feel
like it either the [__] weather was
terrible it's like a sauna outside it
was [__] dark and hot tell me about
it I got up and say man I'm gonna go for
a ride went outside went oh never mind
it was overcast and it was raining
didn't it rained here a couple times but
it was mostly just raining all around me
and it was [__] like a sauna yeah
yeah like a steam bath out there well I
was worried because like yesterday I
leave work at 4 30 because I work from 7
30 to 4 30. so I leave at 4 30 and
literally two minutes after I left work
the [__] bottom fell out yeah and it
was like that the entire hour home and
it was like some of the some you know uh
some of the journey was like total white
out like I couldn't [__] I could
barely see like the lines of the road
and I was like man this sucks so hard
and it was just like in this the whole
way home and I'm just like please stop
it's like give me a [__] break so
then
today it's about four o'clock and I'm
thinking and I see my little weather
thing on my computer being like
thunderstorm and I'm like me I'm like is
this really gonna happen again and then
I heard it like and I heard the rain
like beating on the side of the building
and I was like God damn it I have to
drive home in that [__] again but it's
you know because it's very scary driving
all that way like with all these stupid
people down here they can't drive and um
but thankfully it had stopped by the
time I left and it didn't really it just
sprinkled a little bit like on the way
home but yeah it is hot as balls it's
hot wet well yeah I was like walked out
[__] as soon as that [__] hit me I
was like oh I'm not putting my arm
around
it just wears you out just like walking
outside you're just like Ugh it just
makes you so tired it drains all your
internet chores to do in the house I'm
marinating a bunch of pork downstairs oh
are you you didn't tell me about that
yeah it's in it's in uh Desi yogurt yeah
with uh some of that new garam masala
uh and some turmeric and some uh
cashmere chili and it's just in there
marinade cubes of cubes of that pork
tenderloin yummy yeah and I don't think
they eat pork in India but I don't give
a [__] I'm not in India all right that's
the meat that I got that's the protein
I'm going with I've done it before yeah
we'll just do it it's [__] good yeah
it's good real good I'll just make like
a pork tenderloin Curry yeah it's not
like super authentic but no it's good
anyway I've had some Indians say nah
we'd eat that probably yeah yeah they're
like we're not that big yeah the Muslims
won't eat it they got Muslims down there
Muggles and [__] right but but yeah but
an Indian would they're not that's not a
real common animal I don't think they're
but
they'd eat it can we talk about
um what you made the other day that I
that I had for dinner today the ginger
oh that one yeah that was a Pakistani
mix that's also very delicious that was
very delicious
very gingery I went to spice land
when did you guys Spiceland a couple
days ago oh you didn't tell me yeah
that's where that's where I got all that
stuff oh I didn't know you had all that
stuff yeah with Spiceland we haven't
been a Spiceland in a long time yeah
it's an Indian Pakistani grocery store
you can look at it
it'll come up on a Google search
Spiceland yeah we used to go all the
time outside Orlando what what was that
it's in Lake Mary is it in Lake Mary I
think it's like Berry it'll come up and
it's uh got a real nice staff
the woman that works there flirting with
me and Jenny constantly
Nikki your name is yeah Nikki Nikki
trying to be my second wife or third
wife
that's [__] funny man
they always like talking about Jetty yes
yeah and then um
all the customers there are real nice
they can't believe that man white people
are buying up Indian and Pakistani if
we're like yeah
yeah and man if you ask him for recipe
advice they will absolutely like [__]
I'll be going they'll give you all their
all their secrets I'll be going through
stuff and you know it'll be some Indian
girl do you need help no I know what I
do you know what you're doing
today they're like wow yeah
yeah they must think that's pretty neat
yeah
Caucasians don't [__] bother to learn
how to cook it but I you know
she'll ask me what are you cooking what
recipe you know and she's looking
because yeah okay you know she goes why
are you buying this like she was trying
to bag on me for buying garam masala
and I said well it's pre-mixed and she
goes just you should be mixing your own
well yeah and I said well yeah
I said you know that could be a family
recipes you know what I mean and and I
just like to have have the decision made
for me already because but they're all
different and I said yeah they're all
different but I don't so she's just
trying to [__] lever me into like you
don't know what I know you don't have my
family yeah but that's just the way
cooks are well yeah it's a [__] game
yeah
had to choose to showing her [__] game
on that one okay guys
I got you
um
yeah yeah I mean not restaurants good uh
uh markets yeah they got everything you
can get a big old pack of cashmere chili
it's like two pounds of the [__] for
like six seven bucks
uh the spices are cheap it's like way
cheaper to get spices there than at the
grocery store you're gonna dab 10 pound
bag of [__] turmeric yeah because
everything comes in big giant bags which
is awesome so it's like yeah so it's
like they don't have maybe you know
stuff that wouldn't necessarily be used
in you know Indian or Asian cooking or
whatever but they have like an amazing
amount of spices and they sell them like
really cheap because you know if you go
in the grocery store like he's like oh I
want a little thing of tarragon or
something like that and it's like seven
dollars for a little tiny little yeah
nothing like that but yeah there you if
you pay Seven dollars you're gonna get a
big [__] pound bag yeah like a five
pound bag or something like that yeah
and um you know
North Americans our version our version
of [__] exotic some some exotic kind
of form might be Mexican food like real
Mexican food
well they
the Indians in the pakistanis their
version of Mexican food their exotic
foreign food is Indonesian food
so they got all those damn in Indonesian
cabs and and Thai uh Thai and Indonesian
stuff
big cans but the size of a tuna can full
of ginger garlic spice paste for making
um Thai curry you know you can get that
there it was only like a couple bucks
per can
you can get that same
spice mix in a glass jar that's about
that big it looks like something looks
like a can of makeup or something then
at Publix
and it's one third of what's in that can
and it's still seven bucks yeah so
they're ripping specialty item specialty
item now just go where they eat that
[__] like nothing that's that's just
ketchup for them you know what I mean
you get that thing in a big old Camp
likes three bucks
if you want foreign foods go to a
foreign market
well yeah because that's where they're
gonna go and Shop yeah that's where
they're going it's like they don't well
yeah because if you're just going to a
groceries yeah what if you're just going
to a regular grocery store like I said
sometimes they'll have that stuff but
it's not a big seller it's a specialty
item so they're gonna get like a premium
for it obviously
um yeah gramter says I usually get goat
vindaloo at Indian places yummy as [__]
yeah yeah I don't think I've ever had
goat vindaloo but I've had like um a
goat a goat Curry that they used to have
at what was that other
uh Indian restaurant that we used to go
to before we found memories of India
what the hell is the name of that place
[__] now I can't remember I forgot I
forgot to but they had like us yeah yeah
they had goat there guys I said goat
it's good it's sometimes they have it at
um Fifth Element too yeah but it depends
on the dash it's kind of like lamb and
[__] but it's not as gamey as lamb I
really like lamb though a lot I know a
lot of people don't yeah I mean it's a
mixed bag a lot of Americans don't like
it and it's like even it's weird because
if you go in like a just a regular ass
grocery store it's like sometimes
they'll have like a couple packets of
lamb chops or something like that but
that's about it yeah you know what I
mean it's like obviously they have it at
butchers and stuff but it's kind of hard
to get hold of
but I don't know I really like lamb yeah
and honestly memories of India makes
like the best lamb korma ever yeah oh my
God it's so [__] good yeah it's so
good that it's like every time I go
there I always because they have an
extensive menu and I'm always just kind
of like oh I should get something else
like something I haven't had before but
every but the pull of the Lamb corn is
just too strong it's good yeah and then
Karma does have its own pool
it does well I think I usually get that
too because I mean most of the dishes
that they have like you make them and
you can make them better than they can
make it yeah but we don't you know like
I said we don't usually buy lamb so we
don't make lamb korma so I guess that's
why I get it there because like you know
I wouldn't get like you know SOG paneer
or something like that because I can't
imagine that it's better than yours yeah
because you know I can make that that's
no big deal I made SOG paneer without
SOG in other words it was no [__] no no
spinach yeah I use sweet potato leaves
from the garden it was just it was
[__] just as good yeah it was just
the same same yeah same a lot cheaper
got sweet potatoes growing out there and
just pull some leaves off that yeah and
it tastes like almost exactly like
spinach made it into spinach made it
into Indian spinach sock it was it was
actually
what is it uh uh SOG Pollock with the
head Chicken in it didn't have it didn't
happen here
yeah because I think they also have
something called palak paneer Pollock
paneer that's chicken and cheese I think
yeah
I love paneer
I don't know why there's just something
about it
never had one yeah [__] peas and
potatoes but there's just something and
actually fifth element which is a place
where we go which kind of has a um like
a buffet style thing like a small Buffet
they have
um every now and then they make it's
like tikka masala but it's that like
gravy but it's paneer instead of chicken
and it's so [__] good it's like they
don't have it all the time Grandpa's
asking about why saffron's so expensive
I don't know it must be kind of rare and
uh there's they can't grow enough of it
it's in high demand they got fake
saffron it's like fake saffron flavors
I think it mostly just makes [__] kind
of yellow
I don't know if I've ever had saffron I
don't even know what it tastes like to
be honest with you it's like truffles
real truffles are [__] super
expensive
but then you can get [__] truffle
oils truffle flavored oils
you know I mean they taste good but
there's no Truffle in that
yeah well I mean anytime you have a
premium like thing like that that costs
all that money like yeah you're gonna
get like knockoffs and stuff and to be
honest most people unless they have like
a super snooty palette they're not gonna
be able to tell the difference I'm sure
I would be able to tell the difference
okay so if you guys want uh uh to cover
any kind of subjects you can just drop
them down in the into the comment
section if not we're just gonna
Freewheel this I'm gonna get some ice to
be back that's what we do free Wheels
yeah Celtic Angel 73 um and I wrote this
down by the way idea for a show topic
Diane Downs she's the woman who shot her
three kids in 1983. I kind of remember
that actually there was a made-for-tv
movie about it starring Farrah Fawcett
in 1989 yeah I think I saw that movie
like a long time ago so yeah I wrote
that down
and um yeah it said Anne rule wrote a
case write a book about it too
so Camp guy said Audrey Marie hilly is
another really freaky as hell case with
a conniving woman at the middle of it
she's from Alabama too
[__] okay well I'm gonna have to I
wrote him down so I'm gonna have to put
that like in the next poll and see how
that shakes out but yeah
so but right before the show I just I
wanted to tell you this because
um this is something we could discuss
right before the show I was watching a
video because I tell you what like any
time I'm on YouTube and like somebody
recommends yet another video about like
analyzing The Shining you know I'm gonna
watch that [__] all right because that's
just how I do
so this one guy his now his channel I
think is called our archivio Kubrick I
think so he just like toxic stuff so he
sounds uh like Indian or something but
he talks extensively about um Stanley
Kubrick movies
and he had noticed something in The
Shining that he didn't think anybody had
ever noticed before and I watch it I'm
like yeah you're right I never did
notice that before he said I never I
couldn't find anybody else like talking
about this
and it was really interesting there are
several several instances in The Shining
where Jack Nicholson looks directly at
the camera and it's usually only for
like a frame or two but it looks very
deliberate
and he showed like all these examples of
him doing it and I was like huh I was
like I'll be [__] damned and I was
like that's gotta be I mean that's gotta
be on purpose because normal like actors
you wouldn't look at the camera like
they know better than to do that and he
showed a clip too if there was like a um
he's like on the
Blu-ray he's like there's a documentary
about the making of and there's a very
there's a scene where Stanley Kubrick is
like down on the floor where he was
filming
um the scene where Jack Nicholson was
like trying like begging Wendy to let
him out of the of the dry storage yeah
like he's banging on the door
and he very he says to to Jack Nicholson
he says is there any way you could like
look down like at the camera like while
you're doing that like just for a second
so he did do that very deliberately and
like I said the guy had like and he
slow-moed it and everything like that
and there's a really lot of instances in
there where Jack Nicholson is like
looking right at the camera for like a
second or two he's just like glancing at
it yeah and so they were wondering then
I was like read in the comments after
and everyone was kind of speculating
about why that might be what are the
theories
Theory one
um that theory already well I had a
theory too and actually he mentioned it
all right but the first thing he
mentioned he's like maybe well Stanley
Kubrick he said was real into like
subliminal images and he's like and
there's a lot of that stuff going on in
The Shining like to make you unsettled
and he's like so that might be one of
the things that he's doing like he
wanted breaking that fourth wall yeah he
wanted him to like look at the camera
but not make it super obvious but you
would know that something was wrong or
he was like um somehow like looking at
you like threatening towards you like
the viewer
which I kind of like that idea too yeah
also the first thing I thought of when I
when when he was like putting it all
together and I noticed it was that I
thought it was kind of like making a
statement about
um whatever it was that was Haunting
The Overlook was like the camera and
Jack knew that it was there and so he
kept like glancing at it like it was
watching him yeah like you're the
Overlook yeah you're the ghost that was
what I thought of but I mean it could be
like the subliminal thing too so it's
like you would be so the audience would
be like unsettled Without Really knowing
why I was thinking yeah and so those
were like the two main theories
unsettling You by he looks at you as if
he sees you right pulling you into the
situation with him through the screen
like look he looks at you for your
reaction to what's going on yeah you're
there
but it would have to be like you said
fast it is fast like I said he usually
had to slow it down and it was just like
it's seriously like two or three frames
yeah but he was he was very deliberately
like looking right at the camera because
if you look at it too long it would
spoil it because yeah it would it would
people would go that's bad acting but if
it was real fast it would be like you
said it'd be like subliminal yeah you
felt that you're there like you were
there he looked at me so I'm there with
them
yeah but you wouldn't recognize what
made you on
made you feel uh
unsure about her unsettled because it
didn't happen long enough for you to
recognize it he did look at you yeah
because I didn't I didn't notice it yeah
for sure and I and I've seen that movie
like probably man Kubrick being Kubrick
I mean he was he he's he's a master you
know what he's doing and all of his
movies are masterpieces
2001 is a masterpiece all kinds of weird
[__] happens in 2001. now I know what
happened you know I read the book and
then I saw 2010
if you don't see 2010 it leaves 2001
leaves you baffled but no it makes
perfect sense
once you understand what happened in
2010 and what's happening but if that
movie was way ahead of its time
basically about Ai and transhumanism and
you know what they call it Singularity
what do they call it when he when
computers become uh [__] sentient
um didn't you just say it the
singularity The Singularity is that it's
called
and then they're uh
uh talk about exit you know
extraterrestrial
life
which would be transhuman it wouldn't be
biological
and um
that was that unsettled a lot of people
back then because that was that was too
too much of a futuristic idea
for most people you know aliens were
little green men from Mars
they were going to be human-like
flying ships
and the Extraterrestrial in 2001
had gone beyond biology
it was just the only physical form it
it needed was just to monolith and it
could and the monolith could do anything
it was the ultimate expression of
technology and life
there's Godlike basically
seeding the [__]
seeding the the the the Galaxy or the
universe with life as it went and
watching them grow and there was a lot
of them
and they weren't it wasn't kind of like
a single creature per se just kind of a
Supreme intelligence
it's just a wild story
way ahead of its time but they were
talking to you know Kubrick is talking
to Arthur C Clarke and other people you
know real scientists you know what would
his it's a very scientific movie and
even the space
sequences are super accurate there's no
sound they'll just play music
because there's no sound in space you
know
and um just it was an awesome flick
and what happened with how
why how malfunctioned he didn't really
malfunction
just
they asked him to lie and he couldn't
lie he had to continue the mission so
and I want to spoil it if you guys
haven't seen 2010 but it's it's answered
in 2010 why Hal did what it did
but uh also a great flick and people
don't pick that one apart as much
I mean people do but I feel like 2001 is
more cerebral so it's perhaps not as
approachable it's long too as The
Shining
um whereas I feel like The Shining you
can you don't have to like get into the
crazy conspiracy theories you can just
watch it as like a scary horror movie
whereas 2001 I mean you really have to
kind of like invest and experience it
you know what I mean and it's dry it's
not just a casual watch it's dry and
clinical because it's supposed to be
because you're dealing with like the
best of Mankind's and they're scientific
[__] they're not real emotional
and they're doing [__] that's off world
and corporations and stuff are involved
and uh
when you're dealing with Bowman and the
crew they're basically if you read the
book They're basically human Perfection
they're perfect in every way those guys
that they were selected for that mission
everything about them was perfect and in
their training and their reactions and
their thinking you know they were
[__] basically geniuses
and uh they were good at [__] space
capsules and [__] out thinking things
but they couldn't out think that
computer and that's kind of like the
uncomfortable things that computer the
how the HAL 9000 computer was Superior
to them
and sacrificed them
um because it was kind of told to
because it and it was telling the truth
you're saying why is all this happening
he says this can only be accounted for
by human error and it was telling the
truth it wasn't lying
it was killing people because of human
error they told it to lie
and a computer can't lie
so I just thought it was a great great
flick and what happens to the the
characters what happened to Bowman and
what happened to [__] Hal is covered
in the in the in the movie The in 2010
movie and there's a book too
and uh
the movie's good people forgot about
2010 and Roy schreider in it yeah
Schneider Schneider yeah uh a good flag
not as good as 2001. he has a director
but it's true to 2001. true to the story
I really I recommend it good flip
yeah Camp guy is talking about
um Woody Allen breaking the fourth wall
all the time in his comedies and as a
matter of fact
um the guy that made the video about The
Shining he was showing examples he's
like usually he's like you know people
in movies like break the fourth wall all
the time but usually it's done like very
very deliberately and he did Show an
example of like a Woody Allen movie
where Woody Allen was like talking to
the camera and like talking to the
audience and then he showed um bits of
Like Home Alone where the kid like looks
at the camera and you know puts his
hands on the side of his face or
whatever Macaulay Culkin and um I think
he showed parts of like uh The Strangers
where the guy like turns his head and
like Winks at the audience [__] like
that so it's like so he's like but the
thing that Kubrick is doing in The
Shining that Jack Nicholson is doing The
Shining he's like this is not like that
it's like you can tell he's like most of
the time he's like I seriously don't
think anybody else ever noticed it and I
for sure didn't notice it and most of
the time you had to like slow it down
like I didn't even really notice it when
he played the scene fast but then when
he slowed it down you'd be like oh yeah
holy [__] look at that like there was
like a frame or two where he actually
did like look right at the camera and so
like I said if it had been too
deliberate
then people would because I think
because like I said you know Kubrick
used a lot of [__] in The Shining
that would deliberately like unsettle
people I mean I think pretty much
everybody knows that the Overlook Hotel
which was built entirely as a set at
least the inside like the outside that
used a real hotel but the inside they
built it and the the geography of it the
architecture of it is impossible
um people have made floor plans of the
Overlook and stuff and it doesn't make
any sense and he did that on purpose
like he did everything that he could
just to subliminally make you
uncomfortable like without knowing why
you were uncomfortable Camp guys talking
about how the hell had secret orders
that the crew couldn't know yeah but
that was basically a tantamount to
asking him to lie because he had to
he had to conceal the nature the true
nature of the mission that they were on
because uh Bowman and uh the other
crewman didn't know what the mission was
they thought it was just had something
to do with Jupiter
they didn't know that they were going to
see where that message the signal that
got sent from the monolith on the moon
it was getting sent somewhere out
outside the orbit of Jupiter that's
where they're going
and uh
how suspected that the crew was finding
out what the mission was
and uh
I remember exactly what happened Hal
started to kind of fake malfunctions
to fool them into going outside the
craft and kill him killing them because
he
he wasn't allowed to let them know what
the mission was and they were finding it
out and then they also said we're gonna
have to turn the computer off and after
that how I was like oh [__] no they're
[__] because Hal was instructed that
he was basically in charge of the
mission really because he had the
greatest chances
of completing the mission more than the
humans
because he was better than them
in a lot of ways for this Mission so uh
he ended up wiping the crew out
so he could continue the mission
and that's covered in a second in the
second
movies
it's great to uh yeah and it had to do
something somebody I remember who it was
I think Ben was saying had something to
do with uh
Jupiter becoming a second son yeah they
were going to turn the the the the
monolith alien
aliens
there's more more than one monolith
there's a bunch of them
they were going to turn Jupiter into a
small Sun
because of Europa there was life on
Europa and they wanted to it to
accelerate the life
and make it a warmer better place for
intelligent life
because they were these monoliths if you
go back to the beginning of 2001 the
models was looking for looking for and
trying to help create sentient life
it had chosen Australopithecus
to become a sentient human life form
it's like yeah they'll do yeah in the
book The monolith appears and scans them
oh and then takes over their minds and
puts them through all these exercises
and tests how smart they were makes them
throw rocks and hit targets uh
exercises their minds tries to see if
they can solve puzzles and they don't
know what the hell's going on
and it improved them in a way
when it left they went out started to
fight for survival to kill the animals
that were eating up all their food
and they did it with a bone bones and
weapons
and uh later on they started killing
other enemy tribes
in the book
one of them realizes that
you could use a bone to kill a jaguar
and then put the head of the Jaguar on
the end of the bone and [__] and and
you can kill you can make that Jaguar
kill again which that was blew his mind
okay that was his version of technology
and eventually you know in the movie
they throw the bone in the air and it
spins and it evolves and transforms into
a nuclear weapons platform that's
[__]
uh orbiting the Earth that the bone led
to space travel and it was Weaponry
mates which it did that was part of the
weapon trees what brought you into space
you know V1 rocket V2 rocket
it's all
War technology accelerated mankind
and it's accelerated Mankind in the
pre-human phase with just bones bones
and eating enemies
because the enemies were eating all the
plants so [__] [__]
eating all the plants so don't eat my
kale yeah the model has said become
meat eaters and eat your enemies eat
them [__] animals that are eating up
all the plants you're like these tapier
looking things like a pig
Dave is here yeah hey Dave what's up
we're probably staying in tonight yeah
but I'm sure you're probably you're
probably we got tomorrow if we want to
go out yeah that's true yeah I mean
because like I said I'm kind of worn out
yeah you got up at five also this
morning yeah sometimes he gets up same
time as me sometimes not but you
probably had a nap in the day yeah and I
did not
but you said you didn't really want to
go out today
yeah
yeah Dave said uh on my way home from
getting hair did I'm going to mannequins
get his hair did all right that's pretty
funny yeah this time I went to
mannequins
I tried to fight two dudes that were
like six one remember them yeah I
remember yeah they were kind of seems
like what well yeah it just seems like
we always like it's always a
troublemaker I staged I staged an
incident I backed up into him and
Spilled
come on I started trying to fight him
and that got them kicked out and they
were like we're gonna get you
[__] do you bring that channel
you bring that Center
but man if I keep going on there having
to fight all these dudes eventually one
of them's gonna kill me they're gonna
run into a [__] that's crazier
than me
that's what I mean well it's like I I
mean that's why like it's a fun place
but it's just always like you always
might have to [__] do something right
because there's just so many like
there's a lot of cool people there but
then there's like just a large
percentage of douchebags also and you
always have to [__] deal with these
stupid douchebags yeah they don't
understand they don't know how to behave
they know how to behave they don't know
oh my God am I gonna have to punch
another [__] when girls are out
there dancing don't make a big deal out
of leering over them and [__] you
know get the [__] get away from them
just enjoy from a distance
you know what I mean [__] knock it
the [__] off yeah I don't really I mean
did they like not learn like the most
basic [__] not even the most basic
because it's like man they'll get all up
in your [__] this ain't Pakistan
well the weird thing about this is like
I don't know why this like irritates me
so much but I mean it's called Mannequin
so they have like a lot of obviously
mannequins around the place yeah and
they have like a lot of those kind of
like real dolls or like those realistic
looking sex dolls they have one that's
like laying on the bar and I swear to
God like so many people like these drunk
basic ass people come in and they're
just like ooh a butt and they're just
like oh take a picture of me hitting the
butt explosive girls and I'm just like
yeah yeah it's done and it's mostly
girls doing it yeah a fake butt wow yeah
that's that's really amazing I'm like
what the [__] uh yeah Dave said lots of
people going to Tampa for oh that's
right the assemblage 23 shows tonight
that's right okay so a lot of people are
going to that yeah Dimitri was selling
tickets uh last Friday yeah
I like them I'm not like I don't like
them enough to like pay to see them
though you know what I mean
um what's happening tomorrow Dave what
it mannequins it's what the [__]
Saturday no at uh barbarella's it's uh
it's 80s like always yeah you want to go
to that maybe yeah I mean I like I like
Barbarella yeah
like I said we took Sophie to mannequins
yeah and that was the night that that
dude tackled me yeah that was special
um so she wasn't super into that but we
took her to Barbarella on Saturday night
and she loved that yeah because that's
like a bunch of it's not all old [__]
but it's a lot of old [__] or a lot
of people that have known each other for
a long time yeah it's all seen people
and it's all people that kind of know
each other and they're just all there
they're like look we just like post bunk
and like 80s New Wave we just want to
dance and hang out it looks like this
it's very drama free which is yeah his
late 20s to 50s yeah or 60s actually
even there's a couple little eggs
creeping into their 60s yeah but they've
just been around forever it's a very
chill Vibe yeah it's a very chill Vibe
and I like it because you can just go
and everybody has their own thing going
on and you can just go and dance to the
music and it's like No One's Gonna [__]
with you no one's gonna run into you No
One's Gonna grope You No One's Gonna the
girls Leah Richie or stare at you or
anything the girls can wear whatever
they want as scantily as they want and
everyone's just like what else you're
asking me hanging out the bottom and
it's and [__] everybody's like yeah
you're around a mature audience yeah
they're [__] with you that's what I
mean that's why I'm not really into and
like honestly I have mannequins like
those people are way old enough to know
better yeah but they just act an ass
like when they go in there and I don't
know like they act like they've never
been out in public before I don't really
think a lot of them
well you know maybe David so I can um
say something about it I think uh I
think they're not well versed in the
club culture
bars Maybe
that's what I mean it's a well that's a
whole different vibe like going to like
some jock bar sports bar or something
like that yeah that [__] maybe flies in
there I wouldn't know I don't go to
those but um well they're more like
sports bars nothing really flies in
there because they're not really they're
just acting an ass it's kind of like
being they're not doing anything
you know what I mean yeah they misbehave
I think um I mean they can't do a single
thing without being obnoxious yeah it's
befuddling well when they get into a
real Club I think they they feel
liberated or something so they think
that they can misbehave
but they don't really know they don't
really know what is what the parameters
I don't think they have the the they
don't have the proper [__] uh window
of operation you know what I mean they
don't what do they call it the uh the
Overton window they don't know what's
acceptable
they don't know the culture
well I mean I kind of feel like most
places it's not a good idea to just go
up and like start grinding on random
chicks yeah
like they do that [__] in sports bars
though like I said maybe they do that
there and maybe although I feel like
some chicks in there but they probably
like yeah yeah get the [__] off well it
could be that they see some chick she's
dressed differently you know what I mean
or
she's wearing something that's kind of
revealing as well she's a hoe I can do
it well see I think that's the problem
and that's something I think it's not as
bad as it used to be
but I think that is a a very common
misperception that normies have about
yeah goth chicks is that oh because they
look weird or sometimes they're wearing
like skimpy clothing or so and it
doesn't even have to be skimpy clothing
but it's just they're like oh they must
be freaky so I can do whatever the [__]
I want yeah
well okay here's probably a better
example because I I never really think
about it much
trying to wrap my head around it now
they really went [__] crazy when
defense showed up oh yeah got this girl
named defense mechanism defense
mechanism and she's famous she you know
in the scene she's in the scene she's
famous she has these fantastic outfits
all [__] dig up some video of Defense
she looks like something from another
planet and she'll have like
LED fans and she'll be doing fan dances
and I mean you you basically have to
hire her to come to parties and events
she'll do things up on stage with rock
stars and [__] she's
she's the real thing she's got [__]
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars of outfits
some of them have stilts don't they
yeah that's right yeah yeah she comes in
she's like eight feet tall because then
she did a couple shows that um Escape I
think and she had the stilts and
everything yeah and she can dance
um her face is all pierced it's got big
spikes coming out of her [__] mouths
and [__]
I'll try to find her there's a picture's
worth a thousand words
but anyway she came Yeah man they hired
Tom big time not this time but big time
the guy that owns mannequins
um he hired her
for a show like for a night a few months
ago yeah and so she came she showed up
and she's got to have bodyguards to keep
the people because they're going to want
to get right up on it and look at it
become a part of the show not realizing
that she's a paid performer
all right and they've never seen
anything like that
they don't know how to act
I just like I said I kind of feel like
in this day and age you'd think that
people would like have seen it all by
now but they just they all just seem
like Rubes yeah to me yeah they're like
rude
I mean maybe because it's Florida I
don't really know
Dave says I've told them there if
they're wearing trucker hats or sports
shirts charge them twenty dollars
instead of letting them in for nothing
yeah I kind of feel like there should be
some distance disincentive yeah you know
what I mean like at least like charge
them a cover charge or something like
that like if they're not gonna do it
you know I mean that's the way they
could have a dress code is they could
say well we don't have a technically
address code you can come in if you're
dressed like a normie but you gotta pay
and like if you're not you don't have to
pay you know like if you got the if you
got the clothes on
but for some reason I don't have a
connection
yeah you've been losing your yeah losing
all my actions all the time losing my
connection says I'm connected but uh
okay it's now starting to work Facebook
wasn't working
well Facebook's been glitchy today not
for me but like I wasn't on there much
but I saw some other people complaining
about it
so they have things every now and then
like people's photos appearing and
disappearing and whatnot messages
appearing and disappearing
[__] like that
but yeah it's funny because I had
actually forgotten about that [__] shoe
the last time we went to bed again I
guess just because that time that I got
tackled and you like you know had that
dude in a headlock or whatever it's like
that was kind of like the high bar so
it's like everything that's not quite
that you know what I mean it's just kind
of like oh yeah yeah that was more of
the same I was kind of like
[__] questioning myself after that
like maybe I had overreacted you were
like no no no they deserved it no I told
you I feel guilty about it well like you
didn't see some of the [__] because I
think you went out back like onto the
patio which I don't like to go out on
the patio because it's [__] hot out
there so um so but sometimes he'll go
out there and see what's going on
because sometimes there's a DJ out there
or whatever
so I was in there dancing and these
dudes the irritating thing about them is
that they don't do anything well some of
them don't but some of them don't do
anything super overt but you know that
they're I mean you can just tell that
they're like causing trouble they're
like taking up way too much room they're
dancing like way too close to people
they're kind of like making fun of
people like they're kind of like doing
you know what I mean they're like
mocking the other people dancing and
it's just kind of like they're just like
like I said they're taking up too much
it's not a big dance floor so it's like
you kind of have to just go and find
your spot and just kind of stay in that
spot you know what I mean and like do
your thing in that spot and not [__]
fling yourself all over the [__] [__]
but apparently a lot of people don't get
that memo and they think they're just
gonna like [__]
you know
galavant all over the [__] place and
they're gonna piss people off and you
know one of these days me or Tom are
gonna punch one of the [__] in
the face that's defense that's defense
mechanism
and that and she's actually
it's actually kind of just
she's not all that wild in that one
that's a good outfit though yeah
let's see if I can find okay
this one's pretty wild
yeah she's got great outfits yeah
didn't she used to be roommates with uh
what's her name yeah with Crystal
Crystal yeah that's right she's also
friends with Alexa
they're talking about um
Camp guy talking about collecting
Stephen King books
She always reminded me a little bit of
um
what am I thinking of
Lena Lovich
I don't know who that is am I thinking
of Lena love it she you know lavishes
she looks kind of like her
I used to have those contact lenses yeah
I think they ripped though or I lost
them or something ooh you made my [__]
go all dark did it yeah look what she
did
how'd that happen because you keep
putting stuff in the camera oh look at
look at this this is a great outfit
like something out of Gwar
that's right she had those big like tall
things big tall things and [__]
because like I said I remember her doing
some shows at Escape yeah and she had
those big tall things
right she did some shows there yeah
because they had the stage and
everything
yeah it's funny because when she came to
mannequins I was surprised because we
hadn't seen her in a while and I was
like holy [__] she's still around
but yeah she does all that so yeah so
she came there and you know they don't
really
mannequins has like a little bit they
don't really have a stage per se they
have like a little area that's raised
but it has a stripper pole on it so of
course all the normies like I always
trip or pole and they have to go and
like do you know
hold my purse put the shoes on the
center right and all that kind of [__]
this is like every time we're like oh my
God and they have like a [__] they're
gonna take their shoes off oh they're
gonna put their things and they're gonna
put all their circles all their purses
yeah I've driven them off Jake could
tell the stories I've driven off the
dance floor remember they from girls
a little bit and all of a sudden I said
[__] it they're getting out of here I'm
getting them out of here I just started
just [__] grabbing one of them start
Dirty Dancing and [__] just chased them
all off I can get the [__] out or went
back to dancing
they left well the thing about it is
that they were just acting like I said
the one the dance floor is very small if
you're not gonna dance or if you're just
gonna stand there like they're just
standing out there just like they're
just kind of standing there and doing
that it's just like [__] move it like
people actually want to dance go stand
somewhere else and do that stupid [__]
most of them were just you're in the way
standing in the Dance Floor jumping up
and down
uh with their purses on the floor
which that's you don't [__] do that
all right well here's and it had one of
them that was just running around
hopping like a bunny and and yeah
she was the one that made me go like I'm
getting them out of here I know I was
like oh my God
hop up and down like a bunny and run
into people
yeah like why I went on for about 20
minutes and I'm gonna get him out of
here time for them to go to go to the
next Club yeah go somewhere else go
somewhere else I think that [__] is cute
I don't think that [__] is cute I think
it's super obnoxious long ago she looks
amazing
she's an alien yeah yeah yeah
we're telling these stories sometimes I
have to dig up photographs to show to
people so you understand the scope of
what we're talking about
I'm talking about little two-bit [__]
and like little two-bit people like us
we're like
you look two bit on this one no we don't
well we're classy as [__] but we were
like dressed up in some of these huge
events that you go to it's like that
like that and some of the people that we
know because you know of the Jan's
[__]
companies that were running and
everything would [__] doing album
covers for people and photographs and
posters
so they're kind of clients of ours A lot
of them
so we know them
and the thing about what was that all
the club Owners and people that throw
the DJs and everything
going all the way down into Tampa
yeah I do a lot of so I do a lot of work
for yeah for Tampa and so Jen's Pride
known him for 20 years I've known him
for probably [__] 15.
yeah yeah
well that's the thing too that's another
thing that kind of like um that I always
liked about the goth scene in general
was that pretty much everybody is like
has some kind of creative Endeavor yeah
I mean pretty much everybody we know is
a musician or an artist or they make
clothes or they make jewelry or
something like they do some kind of like
creative thing yeah but man because my
friend owns it and [__] when Julian
showed Julia well actually that's her
real name and real name is Julian she
showed up
she's on um Instagram defends mechanism
d-e-f-e-n-z yeah and mechanism mechanism
she spells mechanism like normal yeah
and um
so she shows up
to [__] add some class to the joint
and they didn't know what to [__] do
they all want to get up and dance right
on her and she has a whole security crew
[__] like get the [__] off they're like
what what what what are we doing yeah
get away from that
you know
that is obviously that well that chick
is not here for you it's get out of here
[__] she's paid to be the [__]
entitlement yes no one is these dudes I
feel like no one's ever told them no in
their entire lives because they always
seem like completely shocked when
somebody like pushes back against them
yeah what we're not doing anything even
though they clearly were being obnoxious
yeah
they'd see some chick like that they
think they can make a move on that no
Good Luck Good Luck okay you better be a
[__] big name
from some kind of band or something
it's just I don't know what they're
thinking man
it's just kind of like being a captain
of the team ain't gonna help with that
yeah she's like Captain America
we don't give a [__] about that
the who the what I didn't even know what
pickleball was until like literally two
days ago and the only reason I knew was
because at work we were doing some big
job and the place had a pickleball court
and I'm like okay I'm gonna look that
[__] up what the [__] is that like I
hear everybody talking about it I don't
even know what it was yeah because I
don't give a [__] about sports
at all
and I don't know anything about it so
and that's not gonna change ever because
I'm just never gonna care Never Gonna
care but um yeah let me say
uh Tammy's talking about
um
Camp guy said uh does she have an agent
oh I don't know probably
she probably does she gets like a lot of
gigs yeah
Tammy says are these people drunk uh
possibly but a lot of times I don't
think so they don't seem drunk
some of them some of them absolutely do
they're not more drunk than us
that's what I'm saying it's like it's
all kind of like I'm like well you're
obviously not as drunk as I am right now
and it's like you know and I'm pretty
drunk but you don't seem drunk at all to
me so they're just [__]
it says maybe they're dancing inside
because I've never been on a dance floor
with somebody just standing there yeah
some of them do like um yeah because
this happened at ibar too like you'd get
it was usually like people that were in
groups and they would go out in the
middle of the dance floor and like
sometimes they would kind of like
half-assedly like dance for a second but
then they would just like stand there
talking and like [__] there's a whole
[__] club there's benches and chairs
there's all kinds of places there's a
bar you can go sit there on stools
particularly these are girls that do
that mostly
they do not come from a dance club or
nightclub background so they don't they
don't dance so they assume nobody else
dances either friends don't dance and if
they don't yeah if they don't dance so
they assume no one else's dances either
so they go onto the Dance Floor really
to be looked at
yeah wow look we're here
wow look at me the thing is that happens
early in the night before people have
really started dancing yeah so they
think it's going to be like that all
night
no people that actually show up
especially people have been in the scene
for a long time start to show up they
start to outnumber them well they got to
get them off the dance floor you can't
just stand on the dance floor yeah we
usually just kind of we're not like
super I don't know who they say we're
not super obnoxious about it because
sometimes you have to be as soon as you
have to be but um a lot of times we try
to subtly yeah get the [__] out of
muscle them up
you know what I mean just kind of like
taking up a lot of room and it's just
like la la coming over here and it's not
I don't want to say it's not about being
a dick it it it's because people are
come there to dance you can't take up
the dance floor that that's what I mean
you know it's like if I look they're
being a dick in my point in my from my
perspective because they're taking up
room that they really don't need to be
taking up because it's like there's lots
of other places they could stand and
hang out and do whatever with their
stupid friends on the Dance Floor
watching the dance floor right if you
want to watch if you want to watch a
dance floor stand off the desk there's
all kind of over there but yeah all kind
of room yeah go over there like I said
people are trying to and gods take
dancing very seriously okay it's like we
just that's the whole reason they got
like a western workout that's the whole
reason they go the whole reason they go
is to listen to the music and dance yeah
they don't give a [__] about patting
fake butts on the thing they don't give
a [__] about like whoo look at me and
like taking pictures and like look at
this freaky place I'm at like we don't
do any of that kind of [__] there's
pictures of us on our Facebooks and
ships mostly those are pictures taken by
other people
yeah they said us we don't really take
pictures
of us I don't even take my phone in the
club here's another thing I thought this
was funny too like I um I don't like
carrying a purse ever like if you got to
because you got to carry yourself cool
purses have you seen them you're getting
a new purse well I mean Gothic purses
yeah I just bought a new wallet because
they got smaller purses that that wallet
could go into that you could you could
actually wear little coffin purses
little [__] satanic little purses
with crosses and [__] on on the outside
of them and spikes mine's got skulls bat
purses and stuff there's things that you
could actually carry that and wear that
person not look like a big bag hanging
off for you I mean the purse I have now
is not huge but it's still
you know kind of a pain like I said I
don't really like carrying [__] just in
general
um and especially if I'm going out
drinking and dancing and stuff like that
I don't want to be encumbered so what I
usually do
um at mannequins or at Barbarella
Barbarella I feel better about it
because it's you know there's everybody
we know everybody there and it's you
know the parking lot there's nobody like
walking around
um I usually just leave my purse
including my phone in the trunk
and I thought it was very funny because
last time we went to mannequins which
was last Friday or whatever and I put my
you know we park in the lot but there's
like a big dirt lot like next to
mannequins where most people Park you
can park along the street like all along
so but we don't ever do that we always
Park in the dirt lot behind the club and
so um
thank you yeah thank you Dave you see
he's leaving oh okay have fun yeah beat
up some normies for us yeah just kidding
I mean if if they deserve it but um but
yeah so I put my purse in the trunk as
per usual and then we walked around to
the club and one of Tom's biker buddies
was there and he said oh she knows
what's up putting her [__] person's
truck like you know what I mean that's
because that's what you do you're going
there to dance yeah you don't need a
purse because otherwise you're just
gonna be like like I said you're gonna
be like one of those chicks that's just
like hey let's all hop up and down in a
circle and put all our purses in the
middle
man we used to like [__] laugh at the
girls that I bar doing that can't do
that in Latin culture couldn't do that
in Brazil
only a hooker puts her purse on the
floor
why would you put your purse on the
floor especially in a nightclub gross
yep only a hooker I don't even like to
put my per and like I've look I'm not
squeamish about germs or anything like
that but it's like I don't even like to
put anything on the floor in any
bathroom anywhere like even my own
bathroom and I know that that's
relatively clean so I don't like to put
anything on the floor so I'm definitely
not going to put anything on the floor
because I was like do you know how
[__] dirty that floor is gross pick
that [__] up you know what I mean but
yeah so I don't even take my purse in
the club anymore because
it's just I don't know it's just got to
be too much of a pain in the ass to like
haul around everywhere it's not heavy or
anything it's just a pain and it's
another thing to forget
yeah and I don't ever need my phone
because it's just kind of like I'm not
gonna take pictures in there it's too
dark and it's like you know
you see people just in there like just
on their phone the whole time and I'm
just like I'm not gonna do that I'm
gonna go listen to music and dance and
like hang out with people I don't want
to be on the phone
okay so you guys saw the fans
um
what else is going on
I don't know
our neighbors are having a party out
there they do that like every Friday
like they started a little bit later
than usual because usually
by the time I get home on Friday evening
they've usually already like they
usually already got the music going
but and it's really loud yeah
I don't know if y'all can hear I don't
probably not
I can kind of hear it and I can hear a
bunch of them out there just go woo yeah
[Music]
and they always play kind of shitty
music too yeah you know what are you
gonna do
less people that most people that blast
music like that it's good it's gonna be
shitty music nobody ever blasts good
music no like all right I don't think
I've ever
have you ever like heard of anybody like
blasting actually good music no I don't
think I can't think of a single instance
every time somebody goes by in the car
like blaring the [__] General he's
like yeah I'm always like so
disappointed one day one day I would
just like to pass a car where all the
windows are open and there's blaring
music it's like something really really
good and I'm just like epic but it's
just it never happened I saw people in
my Facebook feed posted memes lately uh
oh [__]
[__] up facial reaction this is me
listening to new music on the radio [__]
that kind of [__] evidently like new
music [__] sucks I was we I went to
uh
every time I would go down to [__] um
koiwan they'd be playing pop music and
I'm like man people listen to this [__]
no Talent remember that [__] we were
listening to it we're like what the [__]
is this well yeah I hear something I
hear some of that at work too just like
I and and like that's supposed to be pop
music
it's terrible to be fair I've always
hated pop music yeah most of it was bad
even back in even even the even in the
80s most of the [__] is bad yeah you
forgot about that yeah it was terrible
but the shits they're doing now it's
like it's like weird versions of rap but
those dudes Can't Rap they can't rap
they sound like [__] they can't sing
well everything's kind of computers it's
computer generated music in the back of
it sucks and it's just there's no taste
in it at all you're like that's that's
[__] terrible
I mean I can go back to [__] the
2000s and
they still had some pretty good like pop
rap you know but it's just it's all
standards are gone now all standards are
gone [__] it's just [__] total
terrible well a lot of the pop music is
like auto-tuned yeah yeah yeah exactly
so it's not even really
like it started out as a real person's
voice presumably yeah but then it went
through all of these crazy filters well
there's probably no money in it anymore
I imagine probably not yeah
um one thing I did notice about a lot
and like I said this is not I don't I
don't want to be one of those like I
said one of those old people it's like
back in my day it was like everything
was better blah blah blah because there
was a lot of shitty music back in the
80s too not gonna lie but um one thing I
did notice about like some of the newer
pop music is just how repetitive it is
repetitive yeah and they just kind of
like repeat the same line over oh I'm
like okay we get it we got it thanks I
really don't you really don't have to
say it more than who it was and you're
like whoever wrote this [__] has no
musical trade you have no musical
training and it was rap that I was
listening to and I was like they don't
even know rap okay like if this is
supposed to be rap this is like the
[__]
garbage wrap you know real rap was
[__] Public Enemy or NWA and he could
go even before that they had they had
good rap you know what I mean [__]
what was the uh
[__] trying to think of the [__]
the real old rap man [__] um
[__] back back in the [__] late
70s early 80s what was that
motherfucker's name oh [__] no I can't
remember either
yeah yeah
rap was a homemade thing you know what I
mean it was like a do-it-yourself but
those guys cared about the craft and the
[__] sounded good they had good musical
influences
so they they knew the rules so they knew
how to break the rules
but it would still sound good that's
what my art teacher always said yeah you
got to know the real sport yeah the
rules where you can break the rules or
it doesn't work out it doesn't work out
that's good rap they never [__] they
never they don't know the rules they
they never even heard even like I LL
Cool J or anything or [__] they never
even heard classic rap
never [__]
man they Bushwick Bill
mine's playing tricks on me they had a
lot of good rap acts back in the day
although look man the best rap Act
I wasn't big into rap but I was more
into metal metal and and Goth
but there was some good rap out there
and it it it it didn't make it all right
I've recommended it to a couple people
before you can find it free on YouTube
it was it was a band called New Kingdom
oh yeah I remember what you're saying
about that new kingdom was really good
and [__]
the name of the album was I think it's
called Paradise don't come cheap I think
is what was called
I think I think that's what it's called
and it was southwest desert wrap
which I feel like is really a little
explored subject yeah
and it had kind of a Mad Max vibe to it
and they were talking about Jimi Hendrix
and [__] growing up seeing Jimi
Hendrix on a on a on a [__] on a
poster with a with a horse and his hat
and his holster [__] it's just a good
rap you know what I mean and I knew when
he said that
he said he's a little kid in the garage
and he saw that his brother's poster and
it immediately clicked with me because
when I was a little boy my friend's
older brothers I didn't have an older
brother my friend's older brothers had
that poster and I immediately knew where
that dude was coming yeah that poster I
know that [__] poster and then and
then he's talking about he's going to be
down in the Southwest desert [__] you
know surviving in the sun in the cactus
and [__] taking LSD and driving the
jalopy [__] south of the border into
Mexico and [__] Mexico or bust you
know it was just a great [__] lyrics
and uh artistically new kingdom was a
fantastic rap
bad but art but commercially it didn't
make it it went it was too experimental
you know the closest thing to it later
on would have been Cypress Hill
but those guys were Hispanic and white
guys these were black dudes out of New
Kingdom they were they were real good
and they were well known for I think
they ended up in other rap acts the guys
from New Kingdom I think
um but I encourage you to listen to that
album it's really good it's like rap and
psychedela
which is what the [__] is that but
there's a there's like a Jimi Hendrix
influence which like I said I feel like
that's like
um
a genre a sub-genre that needs to be
like expanded yeah
there's harmonica happening in rap music
well and like you were saying before I
kind of feel like
um I don't know and I feel this is true
of like a lot of things and it's like
the reason that I'm into it's the kind
of the same thing that happened with
Punk right I mean you had
you know punk rock that came out in like
the mid to late 70s and it was very
homemade like these were people that
were pressing their own records they
were starting their own labels
um you know they had shitty equipment
but they just made do with what they had
but there was something you know but
they had like a lot of energy and they
you know obviously were passionate about
what they were doing and it came through
like in the music even if it wasn't like
perfect sounding or anything like that
but then I feel like later on you know
the [__] got picked up by
you know more of like in the 90s like
kind of a pop punk kind of aesthetic and
I wasn't into that it was just it's too
slick I don't really like music that's
too slick I don't like movies that are
too slick it just loses something to me
you know what I mean yeah it well it
loses its underground kind of [__]
exclusivity yeah I mean I always like
corporations get involved in commercial
aspects get involved and it starts to
sound too polished and too pure and too
much yeah and I don't really like that I
don't really like that and I'm not
saying that I haven't liked some because
I'm you know some of the like um the new
wave and [__] like that that came out in
the 80s was very slick and produced and
stuff and I like some of that but it's
like normally most of my favorite music
was pretty
Lo-Fi I guess or wasn't like
overproduced that's the album I'm
talking about it's called New Kingdom
Paradise don't come cheap
listen to that album people in there
talking about their favorite rap bands
go ahead and read it off Jen where am I
where are you looking they're down in
here uh Juan's talking about a Snoop
Dogg Ice Cube Coolio yeah remember those
guys so yeah they were good
and um I was always I always liked iced
tea I always liked that he had I always
liked that he had a hardcore band too
called body count yeah it was good I
actually went and saw them live yeah uh
Jackson yeah body count was good it got
in the mosh pit and everything yeah it
had kind of like a punk rock influence
to it yeah yeah which I thought that was
really cool well because um well ice tea
and Henry Rollins were buds yeah so you
know there was all that kind of stuff
Black Flag there's another good band
but um yeah then there was Biz Markie
remember him yeah yeah he was good he's
dead now right I think I think so but
those guys that generation
late 80s through the 90s
they they had a character
you know I mean the corporations hadn't
really taken over yet
so they're kind of doing their own thing
and it wasn't uniformed
they could do their own thing there was
uh
some of the [__] kind of started going
trip hop too
uh with some of that's okay yeah I don't
mind some of that yeah
but that's the thing I'm always gonna
prefer
something that was the product of
um you know people that actually whether
it's music or a movie or whatever like
that was just a product of a few people
like their vision and they doing what
they want to do other than having like
some bigger Corporation take it over and
like Smooth out all the edges and like
make it more palatable to a wider
audience [__] that I don't really I
don't like that because the more you try
to appeal the you know if you try to
appeal to more people like to me that's
appealing because it just becomes kind
of and even like like I said it's it
might still be good it might still be
entertaining but it's just not it's not
forgettable it's not it's not gonna
Stick Run DMC was like that they were
good but they had mainstream appeal and
they kind of watered down but the
quality was all right though remember
Run DMC yeah yeah of course I never
liked that I was around they were gonna
miss you yeah I didn't know if you
remember those guys though yeah of
course I remember okay I remember all of
that [__] happening
actually it's funny because I remember
that I did though it was Beastie Boys I
thought they sucked when they first
appeared but then as they went they got
more advanced and they were [__] they
got weird they were yeah they were one
band that actually kind of got better
yeah some of their early shows
cool is fine but um you know it's just
basic it was very like Juvenile and very
like amateurish but then just started to
get more sophisticated they're talking
about going into outer space and [__]
and [__] it was weird what was that
what was that one uh the guess that was
[__] 96 or 97
um [__]
and what was the name of it it had a
music video and everything
um
intergalactic
yeah yeah they're starting to get really
good
uh Mikester says uh cool Modi yeah
remember that too remember him yeah I
remember like you remember in the 90s it
seemed like there was a massive thing
maybe it was like the late 80s I feel
like too like late 80s early 90s there
was a massive big deal like in the
alternative scene
of crossover between hip-hop and punk
yeah so there was a lot of that going so
there was like a lot of collaborations
between like punk bands and Hip-Hop
bands hip-hop and Goth happened
yeah guess who that was
the last switchblade Symphony album yeah
Tian what is it t in Jam for Francis
yeah for Francis
if you listen to the [__] music
that's all trip hop and Hip Hop
happening in the back with goth female
lyrics over the front it was good I
liked that album but that was like a
dance album I don't think I had that one
actually that's a good one yeah t and
Jab for Francis yeah I remember hearing
about it yeah that was that was rap and
Goth happening at the same time I feel
like every genre of music has been
cross-bred with every other genre of
music at this point so it's like you
can't even remember I said I think I
mentioned this like a while back but
somebody like the guy at work who like
is kind of like the DJ you know what I
mean he has this one playlist and it's
like I don't know I think it's
irritating but um it's called the
alternative
and it's basically like a country band
covering 90s alt Rock okay so it's like
it was funny for like two minutes and
then I was like okay this is getting old
what about dredge Zeppelin you ever
heard them yeah yeah never funny yeah
they were funny
oh my God it was Elvis it was Elvis and
Led Zeppelin like a crossover Elvis
singing reggae Led Zeppelin yeah yeah
and it was like wasn't the dude that was
the lead singer he was like a like it
was almost like he was a fat Elvis He
was like a big fat Elvis yeah yeah and
he called himself tortellvus that's
right yeah
I remember that holy [__] I didn't
thought about dread Zeppelin in a really
long time I remember seeing them 100 or
20 minutes A lot of times back in the
day that's so funny but um but yeah so
yeah alternative so now they have like
country versions of but I have to say
and even given some perspective on it I
think I've said this many times
I'm not a fan of the 90s man I just
wasn't and it's I wasn't at the time and
I said well maybe when I get older and
it's like I can look back as the 90s was
like a long time ago now but it's like
now even when I like listen to music
from the 90s I'm like nope
still don't like it I still like it it's
just I don't
I don't know what it is well no I know
what it is I know what it is
um I think that the 90s particularly
1991 and I'm gonna blame Nirvana for
this but um you know because when never
mind came out and everybody lost their
[__] [__] over it and then suddenly
alternative music was like the hip new
thing and it's like everybody got into
it and then there was the whole grunge
thing happened and then I was just kind
of and I was just not a fan of it and
some of the [__] is good like I'm saying
like Nirvana was good I had some of
those albums
um you know I had bleach I had never
mind I had a couple of those I had um
what was the one that came after that I
don't even remember but I had that one
too I had like some Soundgarden and [__]
like that but it's in screaming trees
and all that and Tad I actually quite
like Tad but um you know so I liked some
of that Seattle [__] but it's like I
don't know after a while it just started
sounding really samey and then it was
kind of like now every time you say
alternative that's what it means now
like and prior to that
you know that word was just like an
umbrella term for just like anything
like
anything that was like too weird to be
like on the radio or whatever so it's
just encompassed a lot of different
subgenres whereas like after
Nirvana happened and they got super
famous I feel like you know alt Rock now
that's like a sub-genre of its own and
it usually means that grungy 90s
sound gardeny kind of situation you know
what I mean and I don't I don't know I
just wasn't like a really big fan of it
honestly I was like um right around
I feel like I'd I had watched 120
minutes which was MTV's like alternative
music show which used to be really
really good and it used to be on uh
Sunday nights and it was always on at
midnight
so it was on from Midnight to 2 A.M
and then prior to that they would always
show like the young ones they showed
like a lot of weird British comedies
like the young ones and the comic strip
and then they had um liquid television
and [__] like that
so it's like so I would always stay up
and watch it and I used to always tape
it like I had like tons of [__] tapes
of all so I had like [__] tons of just
really awesome like videos and stuff for
years and years but then like after or
91 92 I just stopped watching it because
it just seemed like they were playing
the same [__] during the day that they
were playing on that show it's like oh
we're gonna see Soundgarden and the Red
Hot Chili Peppers I'm like big [__]
deal like we see that during the day you
know the whole reason for watching 120
Minutes was that they would show [__]
that they wouldn't show on MTV like
during the day you would see [__] that
you wouldn't see on there at any other
time and so I was like it's kind of
pointless having this show if you're
just gonna show the same [__]
that you're showing in the daytime that
everybody knows now so I just kind of
lost interest so I and I feel like I
stopped
buying a lot of Records too like after
about 1992 Maybe 1994.
because I know I still have like some
stuff from the early 90s but
I don't know I just stopped buying as
much music
because I just didn't I didn't like it
as much
there was just something about the 90s
that just pissed me off I don't know
what it was and it still and it still
does it still does and I'm not saying
there wasn't good [__] that came out in
the 90s because there was there was
actually like a lot of really good yeah
goth Rock in the 90s like I really liked
Corpus delici who were French
um Rosetta Stone I really liked all that
kind of stuff that were more like old
school Gothic Rock like they could were
sisters die form yeah I really like them
we played Symphony I think was also yeah
there was a lot of good [__] that came
out of the Shroud yeah they were great
um you know I'm trying to think there's
like there was tons of other bands that
came out in the 90s that were really
good but it's like I don't know there
was also I didn't really like the
direction
I don't know I didn't I didn't love the
direction away from because like I said
I'm more of like a death rock girl like
I like
that kind of [__] more and it's like so
when it starts going too industrial or
like too ethereal I'm just kind of like
yeah I liked ethereal I'm checking out
some of it's good like some of it's good
these people don't know what we're
talking about probably but you know what
I mean some of it's good yeah
I got a new drink
thank you we're getting some thumbs up
got 13 of them are we really yeah have
we got any new comments in the in a
while because I feel like yeah with the
last time
look at Pookie Pookie you're gonna tear
the books up again she's gonna tear the
books up yeah yeah look look she's
reaching like I said that's why I put
like the old ones at the bottom she's
like why I'm not doing anything she
complains when you tell her no
[Laughter]
she's [__] hilarious
uh John Gore said Lush was a nice band
yes I agree I actually really yeah I
really did like Lush I had that one
album
uh what the [__] was the name of that
Gala was that the name of it I have that
somewhere yeah the 90s goth kind of an
etheric industrial female band called
winch
number one yeah yeah you're pretty good
I vaguely remember that like I said I'm
not saying that there wasn't good [__]
that came out in the 90s it was good
movies it came out in the 90s it was
good well I mean we've talked about some
of them right yeah but um you know it
was good music that came out in the 90s
but I don't know there was something
like the mainstream culture of the 90s I
didn't like the fact that you know Punk
and alternative and stuff got
mainstreamed like um to a large extent
in the 90s and I didn't like I feel like
the 90s the overarching uh Zeitgeist of
that decade was just like extreme you
know and I hated that I'm like that is
the stupidest [__] ever everybody's got
like the blonde tips and it's like
everybody's doing [__] extreme sports
and I'm like [__] that yeah remember
that oh my God extreme cheese yeah
everything had to be like over the top
and like over the top [__] cheese
off yeah that's kind of stuff just
really gets on my nerves
and if you want to see okay if you want
to see a movie that encapsulates
everything I hated about the 90s please
watch the Vanilla Ice movie cool as ice
and you will see what I'm talking about
to me that is the most 90s thing
but please watch the Riff tracks version
because watching it without that the
riftrax version is great it's hilarious
yeah but it's like watching it without
that I was watching the Riff tracks when
I'm like oh my God I know I was cringing
and I was just like I can't imagine
watching this without I'm convinced that
that movie ruined [__] his career I
think that I think that movie ruined is
rightly so yeah
because it was awful we were first
thinking when he first appeared he had
that Ice Ice Baby [__] song it was a
huge hit that he ripped off right he
ripped off from under pressure under
pressure yeah
uh although I think they did all that
under license and [__] they did but I'm
just saying still and people are like
who is this dude you know
well when that movie came out it
answered questions of who that dude was
he was fake you know he's a fake
everything about the dude was fake he
was just something made by an industry
he was he was Frankenstein
um and they tried to propel that dude in
the stardom
poor I feel bad for the guy I don't
think he had any creative control over
anything that he did no probably not you
know he was just an actor basically
and that's what they hired him to do I
don't I wouldn't say he was an actor
I've seen that movie yeah that's not
what I meant I know what I'm just saying
he was just he was just some dude that
they hired to do that
because remember he tried to oh
he once that movie came out his [__]
[__] fell apart and he tried to
reinvent himself he even tried to do
metal I think
yeah didn't he oh yeah I think I can try
to become relevant but
he went Millie Vanilli basically you
know
once they realize that that's not a real
artist
all right he's just an artificial
Construction
he was seen as a fraud you know you're
never gonna Never Gonna complete you
know like when Millie Vanilli when they
were [__] found out that those dudes
didn't sing that [__] they were lip
syncing that the they tried to come out
with real music then we wanted to hear
them
yeah it's like that's what I'm committed
suicide did he I think he might have now
I feel kind of bad but yeah I mean yeah
well that's the thing I mean people
don't really like I mean look people
like some shitty music okay I'm not
saying that but I'm just saying people
don't really like to be deceived and the
fact that whoever sang the Milli Vanilli
songs they wouldn't put them on camera
because why they were fat or they were
fat good looking enough or whatever it
was yeah you know so they're like oh
well we'll get these two models to like
pretend that they're singing yeah and
it's like people don't really like to be
fooled like that even with something
like is insignificant yeah as stupid pop
music you know people took that [__]
seriously I thought that those are real
those guys were a real phenomenon
no
no you can't
very rare that you get two dudes that
look like that that can dance that well
and look like models can sing that well
that doesn't usually happen that the
usually doesn't happen all in the same
person
and if it does it may it you're a
phenomenon you're a unicorn you're a
unicorn
so they were selling this unicorn to the
public
no it was all just a fake construction
you know
I mean I don't I don't know why in Japan
in Japan they love fake [__] like that
yeah oh that's fine but in the United
States it didn't people didn't consider
artists and bands to be real unless they
came up through Club scenes and [__]
playing live music and bars and putting
their time in you know starting off at
the bottom you know that's what made you
a band Duran Duran was like that people
think that Duran Duran appeared out of
nowhere no they were a [__] club band
they were they were yeah they played at
the rum runner in Birmingham yeah and
then that was them okay they really did
look like that and they really didn't
Clips they hang out with Steve strange
yeah now
they had a team of people helping them
write things and produce things and to
do things the right way but [__]
Grand ran the members of that band had a
lot of control over well they could
actually play they could actually play
write their own songs and they actually
were good-looking guys good looking
British guys and they could sing and
they could play instruments
there's another era it was back when
England was [__] cranking them guys
out as part of their [__] the music
education and theater education was a
part of their [__] National Industry
well I don't I don't know if you know
this but Simon Labon was um he was
actually a child actor he was in some
commercials and stuff anyway yeah and he
sang in a choir as well
so uh so yeah so like I said he didn't
and they and like you said they came up
in the new romantic yeah club scene yeah
in Birmingham you know they knew all the
punk rockers you know before them and
they hung and they hung out in [__]
CD clubs and they were poor
and they dreamed of living the high life
that's part of the new romantic we want
to have a yacht yeah that was part of
the new romantic scene is to like is
shoot his shoe or issue excuse I think
it's this is skew poverty because they
were already poor they didn't want to be
poor they want to get rid of that they
want to be rich people to be poor it
sucks so they dress up above their
station and walked around like they were
[__] Rich they faked it until they
made it well another thing that was part
of the new romantic scene well the new
Romantic Movement it was a response to
punk because Punk was very much I don't
want to say Punk was not necessarily
like glorifying
um poverty but it was basically dealing
with the realities of poverty and it
wasn't trying to like maintain it wasn't
trying to make yourself like bigger than
you were more than you were you're like
look this is just what we are we're
broke you know we don't have any [__]
[__] and like you know so it was kind of
like embracing that where I feel like
new romantic was kind of more or like no
we want to be better we want to be more
than that so it's like we want to wear
Lord Byron shirts and we want to be rich
and we want to do this Champion all you
got with supermodels right so you know
and it worked out for them yeah for sure
the guys from Duran Duran had the right
combination first of all they all looked
great and they were all talented yeah
they were all good looking isn't that
crazy they're like five good because
usually there's like one ugly one but
not not so much not so much they were
all good looking and um
a lot of the boy bands that came after
that
they were aping Duran Duran they were
artificially trying to generate that and
you just you can't those dudes were all
buddies before they [__] started
that's the way they looked and they just
all happened to be good looking
and they all they were all talented
and that's that's because that act was
forged in the club scene first okay
nature had selected that okay so
by the time they were they showed up in
the American [__] system
and they have the record companies they
were they had already gone through
natural selection yeah trial by fire
trial by fire so they were like no this
is us [__] y'all yeah step aside okay
give us a team we'll make this a big ass
show when they hit the United States me
and Jen remember we were kids that was
like the second coming of The Beatles oh
big time yeah there was just nothing
like this holy [__] they were amazing
yeah they were amazing those videos man
yeah when planet Earth hit planet Earth
night boat all that [__] was being
played on KROQ not California it was on
MTV too in 81. they were playing in
Mississippi
and I'd go from summer in Mississippi to
go visit my dad and the [__] all the
little redneck kids are listening to
[__] planet Earth yeah and [__]
nice Celebrate song I'm sorry [__]
yeah and and I love night mode I feel
like that's an underrated Duran Duran
song and they all had that album okay
and the video is like a zombie movie
yeah and MTV was out yeah cable TV was
coming out and I told you earlier on in
the
in if you get if you guys are long-term
long time followers of the show
that was the end that was the death the
beginning of the end of Southern Culture
as kind of like a self-contained unit
Southern kids are like oh man there's
there's cool [__] outside of the South
man listen we need to go to some of
these places I mean I want to close like
that
look at how that dude [__] talks you
know I mean it's just so
you started I I couldn't stay on the
[__] Farm anymore
in a way to kind of watered down the
culture but it was for the better you
know I had a choice
yeah you know and um
everybody my age
that I grew up with
visiting down in Laurel Mississippi none
of them live there anymore
they're in Florida
Tennessee Louisiana
Texas they just they you know they don't
stay in Mississippi there's nothing
there not enough industry
but their ancestors had been there for
Generations
you know what I mean you got to look at
it that way
the families that they that they came
from were there for 200 years maybe 100
years 150 Maybe
it's just that's how
that's how altering culturally shocking
cable TV was to the South well
particularly MTV yeah well and honestly
um MTV started when I was
nine and we had it from the beginning
because my dad worked for Cablevision so
we got it for free
so a lot of people didn't get it until
later but we actually got it kind of
early
and
I think I mean I had always been a weird
kid
um you know I was always into creepy
[__] like you know I was into The Addams
Family and ghost stories and [__] like
that so and I was always really shy and
bookish so you know kids would pick on
me and [__] like that but
um I didn't really realize until the
Advent of MTV I think when I was nine or
ten that there were other people like me
that liked creepy [__] and like that
Revelation kind of blew my mind because
I thought it was just me I thought I was
just like this lone weirdo hanging out
in like [__] Daytona Beach you know
nowadays we talk about the impacts of
the internet social media
yeah that was a [__] big change
Jen and I lived through that but you
youngsters don't understand how big
cable was yeah that changed a lot it did
yeah that changed a lot of [__] because
now you you're in the middle of nowhere
and you have access to to things on the
other side of the [__] planet
like okay
the first time I had ever heard
of heavy metal
I was in Mississippi
and it was a dude named Daryl and it was
yeah Daryl was his name I think
no no die Ripple was his last name what
was his first name Eddie Eddie dyrimple
was the guy's name
he showed me the [__] weirdest thing
I had ever seen that was the cover the
Peace of Mind album from Iron Maiden
that was the [__] weirdest thing I
had ever since man wow what the [__] is
that he started and he put that album on
and I [__] loved it
and then he showed me uh the album that
came before Number of the Beast that was
the first time I had ever heard metal
I'd heard it in the background didn't
really know much about it and I was like
yeah this this [__] here this is for me
and then
I ended up liking metal after that you
[__] got the Killers album and then
the first album Iron Maiden and then
later on [__] [__] when uh
[__] powerslave came out that [__]
was good too but they started to go down
till after that [__] Metallica whip
that ass what's that a lot of bands do
start yeah not all of them but for Iron
Maiden they never really could maintain
that that [__] fire that that spark
they didn't because that Seventh Son of
the Seventh Son album came out I was
like yeah Somewhere in Time was okay but
it was kind of commercial
it just didn't sound as hard as
Metallica did you know what I mean when
the Metallica came out
United States started to whip that ass
and then uh it was starting to get into
[__]
uh Judas Priest and
started looking at British British metal
you know and America didn't have a good
response to metal until Metallica came
out
and it's Slayer man they were good too
man [__]
yeah he was from Chile too he was the
weird thing is that I remember when I
was in junior high
there was a big rivalry between the
metal kids yeah and the new wave kids
yeah which is I mean that's sad because
we were all weirdos and outcasts and we
all got picked on by the other people so
it's like you think we would join forces
and that actually did happen later on
like in high school yeah but when I was
in junior high if you were in a new wave
like the metal kids would pick on you
also yeah
I kind of straddled the Border yeah you
liked both things which was unusual by
the time I got into like
11th grade
and see in in my senior year I was
already into girls dating and [__]
getting late and [__]
New Wave made a lot more sense to you
once you're starting getting into girls
[__] there's something about metal
metal is too too male dominated it's too
much serving the the the boyish fantasy
but it's just fantasy okay yeah New Wave
is about [__] real [__] getting late
at relationships and [__] metal has
nothing to do with getting relationships
or a nuclear war a lot of new ways well
yeah there's some of the clear work
didn't have a sense of humor most of the
time anthrax I think that was why I
didn't really get into it like I like
some metal I'm not saying I know but
it's like yeah it just seemed a little
too serious all serious and sometimes it
was [__] it was just too Earnest and
it came across as really dorky yeah
sometimes very dorky but the Pinnacle of
that is Canadian metal known as [__]
well yeah anfield's [__] dorky as
[__]
but they're cringy
that documentary about them is like
simultaneously yeah the greatest thing
and the most embarrassing thing that
I've ever watched I felt so bad for them
and yet at the same time I just wanted
to punch every one of them in the face
I've never really felt those conflicting
emotions like that before but it's like
it's a great documentary by the way
what's it what's it called it's just
called this is Anvil or something like
that we watched it a long time ago but
it's like I kind of want to see it again
but I kind of don't you know what I mean
I felt so bad for those guys but then in
another way I was just like oh my God
would you please just get a clue
John goris said MTV was pretty raw when
it first came out it was exciting yeah
yeah well the thing about it what ended
up happening with MTV is that [__] that
was being played on the radio in 1981
when MTV started was mostly kind of like
still 70s like classic rock what they
would nowadays call classic rock or prog
rock or whatever so they were still like
playing mostly that on the radio they
weren't really playing any new wave on
the radio except for a couple stations
like here and there
so MTV
um they ended up playing a lot of new
wave I don't even think they meant to do
it it was just that the new wave bands
were kind of you know looking ahead and
they were the ones making videos they
were the ones making content and so MTV
were like okay well we have all these
bands that are making videos but they're
all like New Wave bands pretty much like
a lot of the older bands were not making
videos because it wasn't just something
that you did because it was kind of they
were kind of like old school bands and
this was a new medium essentially so
they weren't making them so they ended
up playing like a lot of new wave and I
think that that was
pretty much what introduced New Wave to
and I don't know I mean a lot of those
songs were um did like uh were really
popular and did eventually get radio
play but I feel like a lot of still in
the 80s a lot of the music was still
hold over or was still kind of like
classic rock and stuff because I
remember like a lot of new wave from the
80s like being played in the on the
radio but I also remember a lot of stuff
like John Cougar Mellencamp or who was
just called John Cougar back then
um or Dire Straits or Asia [__] like
that like so a lot of that stuff was
kind of like hold over like you know Dad
rock kind of [__] what's so funny is
that I was listening to
New Wave before metal
because uh when we were in military
school
over in California were talking we were
listening to krlq a lot it was like
Thomas Dolby yeah man you know what I
mean I knew about all that the early
dreads red that [__] was great I didn't
hear metal until later
but I got into that so you could say
that I was started off as a new way but
then got into metal and then went back
to it yeah
but I liked all that [__] side by side
you know which like I said that was
unusual I mean most of the people that I
knew liked either one or the other and
it was like a big rivalry at least when
I was in junior high that was like a big
[__] rivalry
between for some reason I kind of
thought the new wave at first was like
kid music and then I would moved up into
metal that that was manly [__]
like two two years later I'm like no I
[__] dread your air was right I
remember [__] I got that notorious
album I was in Brazil that was 87 like
87 yeah and that [__] was just [__]
speaking to me that was my senior year
of [__] high school up in Brazil
Sao Paulo it was just having a [__]
time in my life in the nightclubs
because you you're in Brazil I was old
enough to go to nightclubs take taxis
everywhere and have girlfriends
you know and you couldn't do that in the
United States you couldn't go [__] to
a nightclub and drink
I was yeah I was always kind of
privileged I guess
but uh
yeah and and like
I was kind of living the lit the lyrics
of that album at least from my point of
view
because that was popular you know
popular them Brazilian girls
I had a girlfriend at the time her name
was norier
I'm gonna dig her up see what she's
doing
she'd be [__] 50 by now
Camp guy's talking about well yeah we're
all the same man and I'm 50. so yeah
actually I'll be 51 in September yeah
Camp guy's talking about Peter Gabriel
and his good videos yeah he has like
some awesome videos like in I think
Sledgehammer came out in 86 yeah I think
because I had that album which I think
was called so and that came out and I'm
pretty sure Sledgehammer came out he had
[__] out before then that was good too
he had a lot of stuff that was good my
favorite Peter Gabriel song is probably
red rain
he did some Er Games Without Frontiers
yeah yeah yeah Games Without Frontiers
that's a great [__] oh I should put
that on my Spotify playlist now that I
think the um I had a soft image but
people didn't realize that that dude was
[__]
he had a [__]
he was a long time junkie he was a
[__]
is [__] on heroin a lot of times and
[__] even they all back then thinking
about his drug problem you know he was
kind of rough you know yeah well you're
not dealing with Phil Collins you know
Gabriel was [__] he was a street dude
you know
yeah it's all right
[Laughter]
Phil Collins was great but my only
douchebag's [__]
douche why do you think there's that
whole joke in American Psycho about him
and the human yeah this thing yeah yeah
I kind of feel like the he like Huey
Lewis yeah
um you know Genesis yeah like all those
people that were into that kind of music
especially back then yeah it was a
certain type of people they were just
vanilla as fun right nothing wrong with
them it's just that they were just super
vanilla super Normie yeah yeah you knew
what you were gonna get yeah like as
soon as as soon as this is as soon as
they said with their musical preferences
that was very safe music
before he accesses that dude
it's the best it's like it's so [__]
funny
I remember you selected J Giles band
remember them yeah yeah I used to skate
to them yeah at the skating rink they
would play centerfold all the time yeah
like you know what I mean I don't listen
to it I still know the [__] words
yeah [__] [__] well see that's what
happens like the music that you grew up
with even songs that I didn't even like
at the time like back in the 80s I still
know every single [__] word to that
[__] because it was like it was
ubiquitous yeah it was everywhere and
like I said when you were a kid
you know every weekend you go to the
skating rink because that's what you did
in the 80s like your parents would drop
you off and you'd go get a hot dog and
you'd skate around with your [__] leg
warmers and and your little lover boy
[__] with the feathers on it
and you'd kind of like
you know you and then what I was trying
to think of like all the [__] that they
would play
at uh the skating rink yeah they
definitely play center centerfold a lot
that was a problem Freeze Frame yeah
that was the other one yeah
um Mr Roboto by Styx oh I remember that
which actually I heard today like
because somebody played it at work well
that was another vanilla ass band yeah
try it was kind of sail away yeah
there's something about it see I know
all this stuff I know all of the songs
yes just a vanilla app I mean you can't
not know them yeah yeah and uh they did
play some Blondie though so that was
something but it's like I'm trying to
think of like what else they would play
all the time I don't understand I don't
think they played today I think it was
some vanilla ass [__] oh my God yeah my
dad used to play that what's that ELO
song
Don't Bring Me Down my dad used to play
that in the car all the time when I was
a kid Boston was he loved that [__]
song Boston they were [__] good as
good quality music all right but it was
just vanilla as [__] too remember that
well like I said they don't call it Dad
Rockford yeah it's like you're dead yeah
and that's what's funny about it it's
like that exactly that's like when my
dad would be playing in the car you know
my dad likes some good music too like he
got me into the Beatles when I was like
really little but the Pinnacle of
[__] style and taste for Dad Rock I
[__] love the band is Steely Dan
Steely Dan is the [__] I admit I like
stealing Steely Dan is really good
that is the Pink Floyd
I love Dad rock yeah yeah they're real
good well actually it's Genius lyrics
that yeah and they're singing about
losers two losers because you're a loser
and I [__] love that [__] we're all
losing the romance of being a loser
[__] and uh of having it all and
losing it and [__] wasting your life
away and [__] because you suck you know
but it's all real kind of pretty you
would never know that that's what he's
talking about
yeah you know just it's just Donald
Fagan
and I liked Donald Fagan's solo stuff it
was good too like yeah yeah the nightfly
album that he had that was really good
he had a new frontier in it
yeah I remember you playing that for
yeah before yeah he was good
there's also there's also something
called Yacht Rock which I think is
that's kind of like I'm thinking like
Air Supply that kind of [__] you know
what I mean you know that kind of yeah
that kind of music
yeah that that [__] that your mom and
your dad would listen to
yeah that [__] that well you hear that a
lot in Florida because like if you go to
any like seafood restaurant that's like
on a river and you sit out on the
[__] you're gonna hear this you're
gonna sit out on the patio and get a
bucket of crab legs or something like
that that is
real wild either that is gonna be Jimmy
Buffett you're gonna get real wild they
put on Rod Stewart it's gonna get real
[__] wild with his ass
you know what the best thing about Rod
Stewart is the fact that revolting Cox
covered
um do you think I'm sexy yeah yeah which
is great I love the revolting cost cover
of that song was that hair real
I don't think it was I don't know I
don't know
[Laughter]
Camp guy said Shock the Monkey is
supposedly about couples jealousy I yeah
oh my God I never thought about it
I love Shock the Monkey that's a great
song and that was a great video too and
that was like one of the um videos I
think that stood out a lot
uh in the early days of MTV
it's funny like I said because at work
today like the guy the guy that like DJs
everything he likes all kind of music so
he'll play like all different kind of
stuff but he did like an 80s playlist
like this afternoon and he played uh the
Buggles Video Killed the Radio Star
and the other woman in the office who is
55 so she's five years older than me and
she's like oh this is what started it
all and like I thought he didn't know
what she was talking about for a second
but he's like oh MTV right and I was
like hey he knew what he he knew what
she was talking about yeah that was the
first video that was played on MTV but
um
I still kind of like that song too
I like a lot of that cheesy 80s New Wave
like a lot of those quote unquote
one hit wonders like pop music by m I
[__] love that song I love that song
like if it comes on at the bar I'm
dancing I don't give a [__] I don't have
to be drunk or anything
um Camp guy says B-52s gals love those
beehive hairdos yeah they had a whole
aesthetic man and actually
um Fred Schneider
he would um he was friends with the
owner of ibar now Barbarella and so
every time he was in town we would
always see him at ibar like he would
always come there like on Saturday
nights and it was funny because he
didn't come there a lot but it's like
every time they were in town it'd be
like oh it's Fred Schneider hey what's
up man so it's like it was funny that he
was just like always there and everybody
was like hey it's Fred Schneider so you
know
I was saying how Fred Schneider used to
come in like ibar all the time from The
B-52s oh yeah because he was friends
with you coming there all the time I
wouldn't recognize him I never
recognized him the only other famous
person we saw in there was Voltaire yeah
yeah I recognized him Aurelio Voltaire
well he's kind of hard not to recognize
it's a friend of mine's day he has a
very distinctive look although we know
this other guy I can't remember what his
name is but we know this other guy who
goes to mannequins and uh and Barbarella
all the time who looks a lot like
Voltaire but I accept much much younger
because Voltaire is like 50 something
he's my age yeah he's like 55 something
nice 53 54 or something yeah he's got if
you guys haven't um he has a great
YouTube channel
called Gothic homemaking it's him and
his
um fiance his name is mayumi she's a
Japanese girl and um they do the [__]
cutest
[__] videos like they'll do like they
decorate their house or they go like
shopping for Halloween decorations or
they'll go to like another city and like
go to all the cool bars and [__] like
that and they're just like it's adorable
they're adorable can't guys tell me how
awesome Julie Dan was you're [__]
right yeah I'm a huge Steely Dan fan
I'll talk I'll talk [__] about it I'll
talk [__] about that kind of music but
Donald fagin was about was a man of
perfection all right and [__]
everything they did was musical
Perfection they were [__] super good
another old band a dad rock band
and I started to get into a little more
recently
going back and listening to Hall and
Oates
they're good
yeah I didn't I didn't like them at the
time I was like I was like man it's
overplayed you know maybe you go back
and listen they were Hall of notes was
really good although you know not on the
levels of Stevie dance the dance was
like like I said they were like the Pink
Floyd of dad Rock what you got there
real smooth jazz real good lyrics
um she brought you some toilet paper
no it's um tissue paper packing paper
where'd she get that from did she get
out that out of the box with my shoes
boxing shoes thank you thank you thank
you pookie yeah thank you good girl yeah
probably not because I hope she didn't
open that box and tear my shoes up I put
them back in the I got new shoes and I
put them back in the Box because she
yeah she'll tear them up to tear her
shoes
yeah she's very destructive
she can't help it that's that's just
uh wait wait I got backed up okay wait
Victor says you're loved by The Outfield
is my all-time favorite song that's a
pretty good song that's a pretty good
song I remember that uh I graduated in
1999 so nine years behind me but for
some reason it was really popular in my
friend group yeah because that song when
did that come out 85
85 wasn't 86 Your Love by The Outfield
you'd know it if you heard it
but um maybe later was it later
I thought it was like 85 or 86 but maybe
it was later than that it's all a blur
uh Trey says wow hey guys long story but
I had a wild day bottom line my mom has
severe dementia oh [__] and I had to
pick her up somewhere which caused her
to freak out and ended with the cops
showing up holy [__] [__]
oh my God I'm sorry you had to deal with
that man that's a bummer can't guys
going on about [__] Steve the dad I
got another Stevie Dan fan in there yeah
Steely Dan Orga man and like I said
we've talked about this before like the
older you get Yeah the more you can like
appreciate stuff yeah although I will
say that some Pookie stop it
I will say that sometimes I hear music
from back then because like I said the
guy at work like plays all cause so we
hear all kind of music like from the 50s
to now
and so or actually earlier from the 40s
and sometimes like they'll play some
stuff from the 80s or you know some pop
music from the 80s or some [__] from the
90s or something like that and I'm just
like nope still don't like it I still
don't like it but some things like you
said like Hall and Oates and stuff like
that which I really did not like at the
time yeah listen to at least I was like
man it's good because it was because it
was like pop music and I wasn't really
into that like you heard it everywhere
and I was just like okay like knock it
off now but
um but the hearing it now where it's not
like in your face every five seconds
like a lot of the a lot of the songs are
actually Private Eyes was good
rich girl
uh there's a bunch of bunch of them that
I [__] listen to a couple I guess it
was a couple months ago and I was like
man this [__] is [__] good man and uh
it's just you don't hear that kind of
music anymore well you know what's crazy
though is that and I don't know if this
is
look what she did she pulled that book
out yeah she likes what are you trying
to go you thinking she's trying to make
a hole so she goes she's going there is
no other Narnia over there
no but one thing I've noticed and maybe
this is just
um you know the guy at work like maybe
this is just his taste but there seems
like a whole sub-genre of bands or
musicians that are covering 80s songs
but like in different styles you know
what I mean yeah so um he has this one
playlist that's all that's kind of like
I don't even know how to describe it
really but it's kind of like Lo-Fi or
loungy but they do like a lot of 80s
songs like for a second you don't even
know what song it is until like they
start singing and they actually do a
really good version what's that Billy
Joel song that's like traded in as
something for a Cadillac what is it
called uh You Oughta Know or whatever I
don't remember what it's called but um
but that's I know the song yeah yeah I
can't remember the name of it but um but
yeah they do a cover of that and they do
um you know they do like a lot of 80s
songs and stuff and they're actually
like pretty good but like I said you
don't realize that it's that song until
like they kind of start like until they
kind of start saying it and it's just
funny that
a lot of kind of like more modern
artists I guess are going back and like
doing reimaginings of those songs of 80s
oh yes John he brought a man-eater yeah
that man-eater is the one that started
me on going back and listening to Hall
of notes I like man eaters I was playing
that [__] Metal Gear that metal gear
game and in that game I it unlocked the
[__] that song and started playing
man either and it kept playing it over
them playing I guess snake playing snake
please can
and [__] man-eaters going and man
that's just tight
to go back on YouTube and start
listening yeah yeah I forgot how [__]
good that [__] was or it wasn't it
didn't stand out back then we were
hearing it on Lo-Fi single single
speaker mono [__] radios you really
couldn't hear it that well
with the old radios of the 80s
but when you hear what they did you're
like going
uh yeah yeah it was good it was good and
you could read you you could reimagine
those songs and re-release them in a
more of a modern yeah format they'd be
hits they were good real good yeah like
I said there's a lot of bands that are
doing that like and they're
reinterpreting them in lots of different
Styles you know what I mean you know
what I don't even know what genre it's
called but that genre with like that's
like really kind of quiet and whispery
like that kind of like I said like Indie
Lo-Fi kind of thing like there's a whole
bunch of um bands doing 80s songs in
that style
well and I know that I mean I know this
because we're in the god scene and
everything but there's like new goth
bands that are doing goth versions of
old 80s songs yeah like there's a whole
sub-genre of that and in fact on my
Spotify I have a whole bunch of well a
starry night covered
um uh voices carry yeah which is great
yeah they got a good cover of it and um
who was it that did I think it was sleep
Thief who are kind of more they're not
really a goth band but I guess they're
kind of more trip hoppy uh and but they
did um they did a great cover of Duran
Duran's uh the chauffeur and they also
did a really great cover of uh the Metro
by Berlin and um I have like all of this
[__] and like um I can't remember what
band it was but I have another one on my
Spotify where they did a cover of um
of Iran the flock of seagull song like
crossbred with sunglasses at night yeah
the Corey Hart song
yeah I've mentioned it mentioned it to
you a long time ago
well it wasn't a long time ago maybe
about a year ago my first wife had a
tribute album
of goth bands doing dead dance covers
yeah I had a bunch of those I didn't
have the Dead Can Dance one man it was
good I had one called goth Oddity that
was all Goth bands doing David Bowie
songs okay yeah
um and then you think you could find the
find them where they were doing all the
[__] Dead Can Dance yeah of course
yeah try to find there's a lot of those
because I feel like a lot of those came
out in the 90s and 2000s yeah like goth
bands covering other
ubiquitous Mr lovegrove they had [__]
all the [__] [__] off of within the
realm of a Dying Sun album they had that
and they were doing [__] goth bad
some of them like almost like death rock
bands doing covers of [__] dick and
dance you guys know who deck and dances
deck can dance is a
kind of like an ambient Gothic bad a
little bit of a world music yeah well it
depending on what year right as it went
on and became World music
it's almost kind of like the Pink Floyd
of goth music
it's sophisticated a lot of wind
instruments and violins and [__] they
had like real classical instrument
people doing it it was just this spooky
goth music
and then it started to go like she said
World music with drums and right it
sounded kind of like African or it might
be like Middle Eastern sound and you
never really knew where they were going
to go [__]
Peter Murphy who is like the lead singer
of Bauhaus once got into a fight with a
model line and and [__] said they
were nothing but selling musical tourism
Musical tour at musical they started and
then [__] dick and dance was saying
well we need to talk about all your
medical problems and he was like I'll
sue you what they were talking about is
[__] drug addiction
I didn't know this until today but he
has actually had uh at least one heart
attack he had a heart attack back in
2018 yeah he's on tour now I think but I
think that he had another one yeah like
recently he ain't gonna live long
the thing about it like I said he can
you know I was gonna say oh he can
really talk but because he did that
album dust but in his defense he is
actually married to a Turkish woman and
has lived in Ankara for I don't even
know how long and he speaks Turkish and
everything yeah so he's got it yeah he's
got a castle they said he's got a car I
don't know his wife is what is her name
she's some kind of dancer that's her
name yeah they they met on you remember
the video for final solution yeah which
was um actually which a cover that was
the cover of a parabu song I think but
um that came out in 85 85. and you
remember that video and it had like a
bunch of like male dancers like ballet
dancers and stuff and the choreographer
on that video was was her okay yeah and
that's when they met so they met at 85
and then like they married not too long
after that yeah and they've been married
since then like for a long time yeah
Peter Peter Murphy was a [__] great
artist all right and uh wrote Good
lyrics he was [__]
in his early ages in his early days he
did a lot of [__] great [__]
unfortunately he declined over the years
a lot of it had to do with him [__]
around with a girl that we know now his
kid but no like it's not her fault yeah
girl me and Jen used to hang out with
[__] was
seeing him all right and yeah whatever
he would come through town yeah and yeah
he was there you know they would hook up
they would talk online and [__]
I ain't gonna mention any names well
yeah I think we already mentioned the
name Sonia
Sonia was a girl that kind of like was
me and Jen kind of dated her in a way
she was just a friend of ours yeah
um we had a little weird threesome guys
yeah
[Laughter]
sort of yeah
yeah yeah it was a weird triangle
happening yeah
um
she was like a friend of me of Jen
she was they
she did like you
but it's just not in her nature to to be
number two she had to be number one so
she constantly had to [__] with you and
that was one of the reasons she
constantly has passive aggressive
passive aggression she would always like
you would make a comment and yeah this
I've known a lot of girls like this not
a lot of girls but I have known some
girls like this where they'll be friends
with you quote unquote but it's like
everything they everything out of their
mouth is like some kind of backhanded
compliment yeah yeah it was like that
yeah like they're always trying to like
make you like belittle you so they can
like be but what was funny is that it
was obvious yeah really obvious and I
would like chuckle and she'd be like
what the [__] is that like she's she's
threatened by [__] you know it just
it was well obviously it's just well
like I said I don't really I don't do
that [__] um yeah I'm just kind of like
I'm very much what you see is what you
get yeah um I don't I don't really like
put on any errors or I don't like try to
pretend to be something I'm not I'm just
not good at that
and I don't really like people that are
like that and so the fact that she I
mean that she was kind of like that but
the fact it was funny because she would
always say [__] about not about me like
I'm sure she said [__] behind my back
because she did about everybody else but
um that was almost part of her stick
yeah I mean yeah it's like everybody
knew that she was like that they'd be
like oh there she goes yeah you know
what I mean like nobody took it
seriously no matter what she said nobody
took the [__] seriously because they're
just like oh she's just being that way
yeah like she would say [__] about like
another friend of ours it's like what a
fat ass she had and we're just like
you're just messing you don't have an
ass because she has a much nicer ass
than you that's us that's us right there
Jen in the blue hair oh and that's Andy
and that's Andy yeah
Andy we still see pretty much every
weekend her and her fiance yeah
her fiance
but yeah she was just uh constantly
talking [__] she was funny
uh and she's older than us yeah yeah
yeah she's older than us but anyway
she was [__] around Peter Murphy yeah
and letting everybody know well of
course she was like a Peter Murphy Super
Fan yeah and then get Peter Murphy in
trouble with his wife there's all kinds
of [__] there it was all kind of dry and
then and then we go to see him live and
she's trying to get up on stage with and
[__] Peter Murphy [__] stomping on
her like
it is hilarious man oh my God I had like
him yeah because remember that [__] yeah
years ago we went to a Peter Murphy show
like we went with Sonia I've seen Peter
Murphy probably like well I've seen him
more than I've seen anybody else I've
probably seen him like 10 11 times yeah
and um but one show like the three of us
went yeah and we were in right in the
front where was it at it was that it was
House of Blues it was house maybe House
of Blues yeah I think it was House of
Blues it was either House of Blues or it
was um what the [__] is that place uh
that's not open anymore that we saw
the generator is that yeah
I can't remember there she is right
Firestone that's all of us right there
and that's Jason that's Jason that's me
in the middle and Jen up against me and
then that Sonia right there
Sonia was pretty she was cool she was
cool she was just [__] crazy and
eventually weighed about 80 pounds and
10 pounds of it was implants tiny tiny
yeah she was Tiny short too she was only
like four foot eleven or skinny big
implants
yeah I got a picture of her she's up on
the box dancing
at Firestone remember they had her up
there as a go-go dancer yeah that's
right and you're up there cheering her
on that was a cute picture
oh I remember that yeah I got it
you got all the pictures yeah I got it
I'll find it I didn't even I didn't even
remember we still had I got [__]
pictures blast from the past
[Laughter]
because this is a long time ago this is
what
well we haven't seen 10 years maybe when
was the last time we saw her
uh well she went back to her husband
yeah so that was probably seven years
ago we were talking about her me and Jen
and Dimitri were talking about her a
couple weeks ago yeah and I was like
holy [__] her daughter has got to be a
[__] Teenager her daughter's a
teenager because the last time well not
the last time we saw her but her and her
daughter came to our house for Christmas
one year
and that was probably like 10 11 years
ago something like that and it's like
her daughter was I think six yeah at the
time so I said [__] yeah she's probably
like 16 7. she's probably [__]
driving which is crazy that's crazy
I'm trying to find a picture
Daniel says Paradise Lost covered the
song uh Xavier by Dead Can Dance yeah
it's awesome Xavier is a good song
I feel like there were especially like
like I said in the 90s and 2000s there
was like a whole rash of tribute albums
and particularly like tribute albums of
goth bands doing tributes to other goth
or goth adjacent bands because like
there was a tribute to Sisters of Mercy
there's a tribute to the Dead Can Dance
it was a tones on tail one there was a
Love and Rockets one I had the Bauhaus
one
it was um who the [__] was on that [__]
there was it was a bunch of bands doing
Bauhaus songs and a lot of them were I'm
not gonna lie we're not great but some
of them were good the Shroud actually
covered passion of lovers and that was
actually quite awesome but you know
other than that I'm just like meh I'll
just listen to Powerhouse thanks but
you know they they tried
but I did like
the one that I had that was goth bands
doing David Bowie songs yeah
like most of those were pretty awesome I
really liked it so it's kind of easy to
cover a [__] David Bowie's songs
because the the the the writing is so
good from the original song and I feel
like I feel like a [__] ton of goth
bands have covered um time at least yeah
Roz Williams did a cover of that yeah uh
Cinema strange did a cover of it like a
bunch of other like goth bands have
covered that song
I got so many of these little [__]
albums
Trey says I would sell my soul for a
night with Terry Nunn from Berlin oh
yeah I haven't seen her in forever yeah
I haven't seen her in a while I remember
her being really beautiful but I haven't
seen her in a long time she was
beautiful back in the day
I remember she had that remember she
they did that song for Top Gun right
take my breath away
yeah I remember she had that great hair
that was like two-tone yeah they had
that video that was on MTV all the time
back whenever Top Guns came out 85 I
guess
everything was 1985.
Trey says man those uh 90s Cleopatra
records tribute LPS were mostly horrid
yeah yeah matter of fact it was a
Cleopatra yeah they all were they all
were I liked the David Bowie one but
like I said I had the Bauhaus one and I
because I remember it had like a um one
of those weird like 3D covers that you
could kind of go like that and I think
they used this still from Nosferatu
I still have it somewhere I just don't
remember where it's at but the only
really the only song that I remember
being good on there was the Shroud one
and I already liked the Shroud the other
ones were just like they just weren't as
good as the originals I kind of like
I don't know I kind of like the the
trend nowadays of like new goth bands
covering like 80s New Wave songs because
that's not necessarily a goth song
um you know like the way Bauhaus songs
were but so you can kind of like goth it
up it's the same reason that I liked
that I like um death in Rome because
they take
songs that are not really God songs yeah
like Love is a Battlefield for example
and like do like a they you know they do
almost like a gothy like Dead Can Dance
kind of version of it and it actually
works out really well either they did um
Careless Whispers they didn't take on me
okay I couldn't find that photo of her
up on the box but I did find this old
[__] club man that's no remember how
long this is this is before me and Jen
were actually a couple and that's
actually me and Sonia
yeah I was I was friends with Sonia
before
I was actually friends with Jan yeah
yeah you knew her before I admit yeah
that was me with blonde hair yeah you
have blonde hair back yeah
yeah
she had a whole she was I think that she
was like super into you like y'all never
dated
but she had a whole I used to laugh
because she had a whole um she thought
she owned me she had yeah she had a
whole photo album on her Facebook that
was called Tom and so it was I didn't
know that yeah and I used to think that
was so funny because I'm like you guys
are like not even dating I didn't even
know that no well no we weren't dating
we were friends yeah I mean y'all messed
around yeah
and then but then that didn't go
anywhere because see she was always
she was always like kind of aloof and
hard to get yeah all right so it was
kind of the same thing and then when I
started out with Jenny she got jealous
yeah she got mad so she had to get in
there somehow
yeah she had to like yeah and they were
like even though like I said that she
they were friends because I know she she
was just weird about the way her [__]
was but the thing about it is that I
know where it's coming from so it
doesn't bother me as much
as it maybe would have otherwise because
I know what her deal is and I'm just
like I know
I don't know I I just know where she's
coming from so it doesn't bother me you
know what I mean
even though I don't usually like that
kind of thing but
she's she's coming from a place of
um
I don't know I I guess like real
insecurity and she has like a thing
where
I guess a lot of people have this where
if you're insecure about something you
kind of like exteriorize it and like
just cut other people down to like make
yourself feel better you know what I
mean but you know she it's like so
transparent when she does it that it's
like you almost can't be mad you know
what I mean
uh Trey said what is that on Tom's shirt
in the picture I'm not really sure
actually I'd have to see it again
because I didn't look at it all that
close that was an old old ass picture
like I said that was
that was either before I met him or
right around the time that I met him
although didn't no
I think I did know him at that time
because when I met him
I think I met him in 2009 or 2010 and
I'm pretty sure he had black hair
because I remember when he bleached it
but I didn't know him that well you know
what I mean like we weren't hanging out
really like I'd know him enough to be
like oh hey dude you know what I mean
but it wasn't like right
yeah I don't I don't know I'm not really
sure I'm gonna have to I'll ask him when
he gets back
but yeah I just I don't know
we were just talking about her the other
day yeah because well I don't know if I
want to say why but because something
came up with Dimitri and Jen
um Trey asked what what that was on your
shirt
me
like like now or in the photo yeah I
don't know what she's talking about
if it's this
what's that on top yeah it's something
Jen made this is actually
um a goth Festival yeah that's in Tampa
every year yeah it's usually two or
three days uh we made this shirt I made
this logo
and they usually have like a whole [__]
ton of bands
that play there we went we usually go
every year because we get them free
because I design all their [__] so
we go if if a starry night is playing
which they usually are
um we go and see it like you know
chlorine played there yeah I love
chlorine
it's a cathedral window
with a cross shadow of a cross on it
right there a moon with bats
and then it's got the [__]
Horizon with like Graves and it says
Absolution yeah Absolution fast yeah
they do it every year in Tampa usually
in October it's usually in early October
and it's usually
I think it started out as three days I
don't know if it's two I think it's
three days yeah if you want one Thursday
Friday Saturday well I want just contact
us directly and I'll make you one
um depending on whatever shirt I I we
can get it to you for probably about 25.
I'm trying to think of all the I did
because I already got um all the teaser
stuff for this year's
and I'm trying to think of the bands
that are playing there but you you can't
like get to invested in it because
they keep like oh we can't calm now and
blah blah but it's like usually usually
a starry nighter there
um sometimes Corrine are there other
band like push button press like I said
Bellwether Syndicate
um I'm trying to think I made this one
for me it's the only one I've done on
this shirt I would have put this a
little bit higher next time I think in
the production shirt on the back has all
the lists of the Bands yeah yeah of the
year but that was designed for a shirt
with sleeves on it yeah okay and we
don't have the back because the back
changes every year it's got the front
yeah we just keep because the logo
mostly stays the same yeah but um they
use they sometimes like change the
colors up and stuff but yeah the back
changes every year because all the
different bands and it's just kind of
like we we've been doing it for
three years four years when did they
start doing Absolution we've been doing
it since the beginning but it's been
like three or four years okay he says
he'll contact us soon all right man yeah
I'll make you one
but it's like I remember last year it
was like a big yeah it was last year
wasn't it we got like in a big huge
crunch because like there was this whole
like some of the Bands had to cancel and
then other ones got added on like at the
last [__] minute and we had to like
[__] reprint the shirts and it was
down to like the last hour or something
like that and I had to come home and
like do all these [__] shirts and it
was just like we were [__] we were
going crazy we were going great that
[__] done to get it done yeah but we did
it thinking about getting that machine
to do the multi-color
yeah we maybe should invest in that
because we can kind of because we've
lost some jobs because we can't do
multi-color
yeah I mean honestly we just started
doing it like for you guys like so we
could do white ink on black yeah and we
started getting offers from [__] from
but yeah right and they're just like hey
can you do shirts for us and it's like
we only need like 50 or 100 or something
like that yeah and I keep going like and
It's gotta be two colors it's got to be
two colors gotta be three colors I'm
just like damn it so let me do one color
yeah maybe we should get that machine
yeah how much is it
under 100 about 100 something
that's not bad it's got like a little
Carousel you got to set it all up yeah I
mean if it would be worth it that might
be something yeah invest in but
just because like I said we've had
offers to do stuff and we just didn't do
it because well we put it out through
the channels that we can do four color
or even five color we'd get a bunch of
responses back okay I need this and that
I need that because they all want black
shirts with white and red yeah on them
yeah I kind of feel like that's the main
thing that they're gonna want is white
and red
Camp guy said yes small batch numbers
are attractive to some small businesses
yeah yeah because a lot of bigger
companies are gonna they want too much
order well they're gonna make you order
like a minimum amount yeah you know what
I mean now it's a pain in the ass
because like I said for the Absolution
one we didn't do a [__] ton I think we
just did a hundred but it was just us
doing them by hand yeah you know what I
mean so we had to like shoot the screens
and then we had to like literally go
through and then we had to like dry each
one with a [__] hair dryer and [__]
like that so it took a really long time
okay we've been streaming for longer
than two hours
um we probably ought to go ahead and
shut it down uh send us some super chats
and we'll we'll talk for longer but if
not we're gonna have to shut it down
or give me a suggestion for a movie that
we should do for Sunday a horror movie I
want to do more horror especially if
it's on shutter or Amazon Prime or HBO
Max or Hulu I have all of those so if
you have anything that you'd like like I
said I have a couple of ideas if nobody
comes up with anything but like
depending on whether you want to do
something old or something new I can do
either thing I don't really care so
we'll see
because I have to look for some [__]
that you would like to look up you know
what I mean yep because you're picky
yeah Camp guy said most big art
producers and t-shirt producers want to
sell you a bunch of shirts 200 to 300
yeah yeah
Trey said y'all done Dark Night at the
Scarecrow yet
um yes well okay I don't remember if we
both did it or if I just did it but I
know one of like either we both did it
or I've just done it
since it's on YouTube yeah
did we both watch that or was it just me
I never heard of it okay so maybe I just
did it then
yeah Trey said wait you did I think yeah
I'm pretty I'm 99 sure I don't remember
I did Darkness scarecrow
but I don't remember if we both did it
or if I just did it by myself because I
do a lot of movie and book reviews I
don't remember that one Dark Knight oh
no no I do remember that okay maybe we
did do I think we did do that remember
they were didn't they keep coming up on
a scarecrow down out in the woods at
night and then it was killing people
and then like if they had a fake
scarecrow that wasn't the scared I just
remember a scene like that yeah
so I think maybe we did see that yeah so
maybe we both did maybe we both did it
then but I'm pretty sure they start to
blur together over a while man well
we've seen so many so many of them we've
seen so many and I didn't see those at a
young age where they'd make a real
strong impression when you get older
that you know your the impression it
makes on you isn't isn't quite as much
it well it takes it just takes more
multiple viewings of it for it it takes
more for it to really like hit you in
the face because you've seen so much
like which is kind of sucky I don't I
don't like it I don't like being older
and like [__] having to be like
yeah that's one thing that sucks about
being older is that everything nothing
nothing makes as much of an impression
as it used to like or something has to
be like really extraordinary right to
like make an impression starts to become
very samey
yeah which like I said but I still see
like a lot of good [__] though I'm not
saying that I got that uh are you hungry
yeah a little bit because I got that
I got that Curry down there marinate and
I can make some of that if you want are
we gonna make curry yeah all right okay
it's Friday night shut down I don't have
to go to bed okay let's go I mean I
probably will just fall asleep but you
know what I mean I don't have to go to
bed if I don't want to already I'm an
adult all right I'm gonna get on all
right so thank you guys for dropping by
this evening and talking about a bunch
of [__] like we always do on Friday
night this is probably my favorite show
to do because it's just fun and kind of
off the cuff and I kind of like that
because I don't have to worry about like
research or anything
so yeah so I'm not really sure what
movie we're gonna do like I said
it could be a new one because I have
some ideas about some newer ones on
shutter than recommended that maybe I
want to see
um if not we might do some old ones like
because HBO Max has like some older
Stephen King ones that we haven't
covered so we might do that like silver
bullet or
thinner or something like that so we
might do one of those but we'll see so
it'll be a surprise for you guys and
it'll be a surprise for us also so uh
yeah have a good rest of your evening
you guys and have a good day tomorrow
and we will see you guys again on Sunday
talking about a mystery movie uh so yeah
we'll see you guys then